MUCH FOR JOINING US FOR FOR A
REGULARLY SCHEDULED BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS HEARING -- FOR FEW
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS THE FOLLOWING
BILLS HAVE BEEN PULLED BY AUTHOR
SB THREE TWENTY FIVE BY SENATOR
HILL AND SB FOUR EIGHTY THREE BY
SENATOR PAN AGAIN A TWO BILLS
HAVE BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
WE DIDN'T CURRENTLY ARE ABSENCE
A QUORUM SO BE ACTING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE AND THEN WE'LL GO AND
FILE ORDER WILL BEGIN THEN WITH
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE WHICH IS SB
FIFTY ONE BY.
THE SENATOR HERTZBERG.
CENTER HERTZBERG WELCOME.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
I'M READY SHERMAN.
I'M READY.
AND I PUT MY FILE UP HERE
BECAUSE I GOT IT RIGHT HERE.
AS THIS COMMITTEE IS WELL AWARE
THE VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA BY A
WIDE MARGIN.
SHOWS RECENTLY TO LEGALIZE
RECREATIONAL CANNABIS.
LEGAL IN CALIFORNIA.
CHALLENGES THE FEDERAL BANKING
SYSTEM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CHARACTERIZES CANNABIS A
SCHEDULE ONE DRUG WHICH MEANS
THAT IN THE BANKING SYSTEM.
YOU CAN'T DEPOSIT THE PROCEEDS
OF THAT BUSINESS IT'S IT'S
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
SO WHAT DO YOU DO WHEN YOU TRY
TO BALANCE ON THE ONE HAND.
THE PUBLIC POLICY IS INFORMED BY
THE VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA ONE ON
THE OTHER HAND YOU'VE GOT A
COMPLETELY CONTRADICTORY FEDERAL
POLICY.
HOW DO YOU SOLVE THE PROBLEM?
THAT PROBLEM HAS BEEN FURTHER
EXACERBATED BY.
THE FACT THAT IS RESOLVED THE
ENTIRE INDUSTRY IS CASH.
SENATE MCGUIRE INFORMS ME DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S ACCURATE THAT
THERE'S TWO BILLION DOLLARS
BURIED NORTHERN CALIFORNIAN
BARRELS.
GENTLEMAN CAME TO MY OFFICE AND
SAID HE HAD FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS AT THE TRACTOR TRAILER
YOU CAN PARK IN MY GARAGE.
IT'S CREATED AN EXTRAORDINARILY
PUBLIC SAFETY -- PROBLEM IT IS
THE TREASURER WHO IS ONE OF THE
SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH NOW FOR TWO
YEARS THEN SHE WAS THE AT THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION.
TALKS ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
ACCOUNTING.
AND RECORD KEEPING IN THIS
INDUSTRY.
AND ALSO IT HAS A HORRIBLE
IMPLICATION IN TERMS OF COST
WE'VE SEEN IN OUR BUDGET BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALS BECAUSE BECAUSE
GOVERNMENT OFFICES GOT A PUT ON
BULLETPROOF GLASS GOVERNMENT
OFFICES HAVE TO HIRE MORE
EMPLOYEES.
IT TAKES SOMETHING LIKE THAT
THREE THREE POLICE TODAY A FULL
DAY TO COUNT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS YOUR ACCOUNT OF
THREE TIMES RIGHT.
HE GOT C. H. P. ESCORTS TAKEN
MONEY TO THE BANK TO GET PEOPLE
BEING ROBBED.
WHAT DO YOU DO HOW DO YOU FIGURE
IT OUT?
INNER THIS MEASURE.
IT IS NOT A PERFECT MEASURE
ALTHOUGH EVERY OTHER BILL I'VE
EVER TO DEUCE HAS BEEN SO FIRST
EVER OMITTED THAT.
NOT BECAUSE IT'S IT'S NOT I'M
THE BILL WHAT IT IS IS TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT A CREATIVE WAY. TO AT
LEAST.
GO AS FAR AS WE CAN UNDER THESE
VERY DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES.
AND I KNOW THAT THIS IS AN
INTERIM DEAL UNTIL THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AT SOME TIME BECAUSE
OTHER STATES HAVE LEGALIZED
CANNABIS.
IS GOING TO CHANGE ITS RULES SO
HOW DO WE CREATE AN INTERIM
BRIDGE THAT WORKS WITHIN THE
SYSTEM REASONABLY WELL THAT
SOLVES MANY PROBLEMS YOU CAN AND
TAKES US DOWN THE ROAD IT'S FAR
AS YOU CAN.
THAT'S AS CONSERVATIVE AS
POSSIBLE AND NOT TOO COMPLEX.
SO INSTEAD OF COMING UP WITH A
COCKAMAMIE PUBLIC BANK IDEA --
WHICH COULD TAKE FORTY YEARS TO
GET IT IMPLEMENTED AND IT NEVER
WORKED THE IDEA WAS TO BOLT ON
TO THE EXISTING STRUCTURE OF OF
BANKS AND SH AND CREDIT UNIONS.
ARE A PROCESS WHEREBY WE CAN
CREATE A LIMITED CHARTER WHY IS
THAT IMPORTANT WHY HAVE WE
STRUCTURED THE WAY WE STRUCTURE
WITH THE TREASURE.
RESTRUCTURED AGAIN BECAUSE IT'S
AN INTERIM PLAY.
THE IDEA IF IT'S A BANK IT HAS
TO LIVE BY AND LIVE UNDER THE
RULES OF THE BANKING
COMMISSIONER WHATEVER IT'S
CALLED TODAY'S FANCY NEW NAMES
ON MIDDLE GUY RIP I STILL CALM
BANK.
PHONE BANKING COMMISSION WE A
NEW BANK COMMISSIONER.
SO THAT MEANS THAT THE RULES
INVOLVING FIDUCIARY OBLIGATIONS
REPORTING EVERYTHING ELSE THAT
LOOKS AND FEELS AND SMELLS LIKE
A BANK ITWILL DO EXCEPT IT HAS
A LIMITED CHARTER TO SERVE FOR
PURPOSES.
AND IT'S WHAT'S CALLED A CLOSED
LOOP SYSTEM WHAT CREATES THE
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IT'S THAT WE
USE THE FEDERAL WIRE WE USE THE
CLEARING HOUSES IN THE FEDERAL
SYSTEM.
WHICH THEN BRINGS IT TO THEIR
JURISDICTIONS SECONDLY WE USE
FDIC DEPOSIT INSURANCE A TOUR
FOR TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS A POP
THAT BRINGS IT UNDER THEIR
JURISDICTION.
SO HOW DOES A STATE ORGANIZED
THAT IN A WAY CREATES A CLOSED
LOOP SYSTEM OUTSIDE THE FEDS.
IT DOES IT BY ONE USING PRIVATE
INSURANCE COMPANIES I'VE TALKED
TO SAID THAT THEY WOULD INSURE
Là COMPANIES WILLING TO TO
ENSURE THE COST OF INSURANCE
EXPENSIVE IT'S A HECK OF A LOT
LESS THAN SECURITY GUARDS.
INSURANCE AND ALL THE THE
CHALLENGES THAT ARE INFORMED BY
ANYBODY IN THE BANKING BUSINESS
I MEAN THE KIND OF HIS BUSINESS.
AND SECONDLY YOU DON'T ALLOW
DEPOSITS TO BE MOVED INTO
FEDERAL INSTITUTIONS THAT MEANS
IF I HAVE THE SAY THE EVAN LOW
CANNABIS CHARTER BANK RIGHT AND
I GOT AN ACCOUNT AT THE BANK
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IS I GIVE
EVAN LOW BANK MY CASH.
CANNABIS BAKE MY CASH THEY
DEPOSIT GIVE ME A RECEIPT THE
BANKS IT'S THERE HE THEN EVAN
LOADS BANK GIVES ME A OUR CHECK
A CHECK BOOK.
THAT CHECKBOOK LOOKS LIKE A
CHECK LIKE THIS.
IT SAYS BASICALLY THIS CHECK IS
ISSUED BY EVAN LOW BANK PURSUANT
TO SUCH AS CAN ONLY BE DEPOSITED
EVAN LOW'S BANK OR ANYBODY WITH
WHOM EVAN LOW HAS IT HAS IT HAS
A RELATIONSHIP WITH.
NOW IN ANOTHER PART OF THE STATE
AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THERE'S
THE GIPSON CANNABIS BANK.
AND SO GIPSON BANK AND EVAN LOW
BANK HAVE AN AGREEMENT I'LL TAKE
YOUR CHECKS YOU TAKE MY CHECKS
WE JUST CAN'T PUT IN THE FEDERAL
SYSTEM.
SO THERE'S AND ALL OF A SUDDEN
YOU GOT OBERNOLTE IN THEM HIGHER
BANK.
AND A BRAWL IN SOUTHERN CAL IN
IN ORANGE COUNTY RIGHT SO YOU'VE
GOT ALL THESE DIFFERENT BANKS
YOU GUYS HAVE AN AGREEMENT IT
DOES MONEY DOESN'T TOUCH.
THEIR NINE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THREE BANKS IN CALIFORNIA
THEY'RE EMPTY THERE ARE CERTAIN
OFTHE CLOSE BECAUSE BANKING
BRANCHES ARE CLOSING.
SO THEY'RE AVAILABLE THIS COULD
BE AN EASY DEAL HAVE AN URGENCY
PROVISION BECAUSE LAST YEAR I
GOT CAUGHT UP IN THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION I BELIEVE IN
EVERY.
INSTINCTS THAT I EVER EVERY
PIECE OF POLITICAL KNOWLEDGE I
HAVE THE DISCOVER WILL SIGN.
KEEP MY FINGERS CROSSED YOU
NEVER KNOW AND THAT WE MADE THIS
AN URGENCY BILL WE HAD ALMOST
FULL SUPPORT BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IN THIS DEAL.
AND BASICALLY THE BOTTOM LINE OF
FINISH HERE IS THAT WHAT DO YOU
USE THE MONEY FOR IN THIS
LIMITED CHARTER BANKS.
USE THEM.
FOR ONE AREN'T YOU CAN USE TO
PAY YOUR RENT I'M A LANDLORDS
AND HAVING SOMEBODY COME A
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
PAY THE RENT THE CAN THE PROJECT.
LANDLORD CAN TAKE AND THE AND
GET THE MONEY AND THEN THEY CAN
TRANSPORTED BY ARMORED CAR TO
THEIR BANK OR WHATEVER THE CASE
MAY BE. TO TO PAY YOUR VENDORS
AND AGAIN THESE HAVE TO BE
CERTIFIED LICENSED FOLKS IT
CAN'T JUST BE ANYBODY PLAN
AROUND.
AND YOUR VENDORS SO NOW I'M A
PLUMBER INSTEAD I GETTING TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO MY PERSON
GOES OUT PUTS THE PIPES AND
WATER THE PLANTS THEY GET A
CHECK.
IT'S A BETTER MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
THIRD.
IT'S TO BE USED TO INVESTMENT IN
THE STATE WITH THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE LOCAL
INVESTMENTS OF OUR MAKE RETURN
ON MY MONEY.
I DO THAT AND FOURTH WE MOST
IMPORTANCE TO PAY -- GOVERNMENT
FEES SO THAT THE GOVERNMENT
DOESN'T HAVE TO HAVE ALL THIS
HEARTACHE IN EXPENSE AND BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALS WITH RESPECT --
TO COLLECTING MONEY THEY CAN
ACCEPT THESE CHECKS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN ACCEPT IT IF
THEY WANT TO IT'S NOT A PERFECT
APPROACH.
A CERTAIN IS A LOT OF HOLES IN
IT YOU KNOW PEOPLE WANT TO GO
FARTHER IN THIS AND THAT THE
IDEA IN OUR DISCUSSIONS THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS THE TREASURES
OFFICER THEN THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION IS OFFICE.
WAS HOW CAN WE AT LEAST TAKE A
STEP THAT WILL PROVIDE SECURITY
ALLOW FOR PEOPLE TO EASILY PAY
THEIR TAXES OR OTHER FEES.
AND AND THE UP THE ULTIMATE GATE
THE DITCH DIGGERS ME TWO MORE
QUICK POINTS ON RACE POINT
NUMBER ONE IS THE LAST TWO
POINTS ARE ARE.
ONE IS THE IDEA THAT THIS WILL
BE EASY TO TRANSFER WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN IS ONCE THIS BECOMES
LEGAL THE BIG CODES ARE GOING TO
COME IN AND BUY THESE PEOPLE UP.
AND IT'S REALLY EASY TO BUY THEM
UP BECAUSE THEY LOOK LIKE SMELL
LIKE BANKS RIGHT THEY'RE GONNA
WANT TO BUY THE ACCOUNTS.
SECOND THING IS HOW TO BANKS
MAKE MONEY.
THEY TAKE MISTER OBERNOLTE IS A
SMALL BANK ACCOUNT AND THEY THEY
GET TAKE IS A THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND THEN THEY LANDED THAT AT ANY
GIVEN 1% INTEREST THEY LET IT
OUT TO SOMEBODY ELSE 48%
INTEREST THEY MAKE THE 7% THEY
PAY EXPENSES TO MAKE A PROFIT.
THIS WILL BE A LANDING IN THIS
BANK WE CALL THE BANK IT'S
REALLY A FEE FOR SERVICE SO NOW
ALL OF A SUDDEN GIPSON CHARGES
ME. THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
MONTH TO KEEP AN ACCOUNT IS BANK
AND EVERY CHECK THAT ARE RIGHT
DEPENDING UPON THE AMOUNT OF THE
CHECK.
HE CHARGED ME A HUNDRED DOLLARS
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS CHECK WITH
THAT'S A LOT LESS EXPENSIVE AND
A LOT MORE SAFE AND SECURE.
THEN WHAT THE CURRENT STRUCTURE
IS.
WE'RE TRYING IN GOVERNMENT TO AT
LEAST TRY TO SOLVE A PROBLEM AND
WE WERE FACED WITH THIS
EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGE HOW DO
WE AT LEAST IN GOOD FAITH SHOW
TO THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA THIS
TREMENDOUS INTEREST IN THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY TO DO THIS
THING.
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE HAVE COME
BEFORE US THEIR ACTION FORMING
THESE BANKS TO MAKE COST TEN
MILLION BUCKS TO FORM ALL OF I
FIGURE IT OUT.
BUT IT IS A IT IS IN MY JUDGMENT
A THOUGHTFUL SO INTERIM SOLUTION
AS WE FACE IS EXTRAORDINARY
CHALLENGE BETWEEN THE TENSION
BUT WHAT THE VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE TOLD US THEY
WANT.
AND WHAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS IMPOSED IN THE LAW WITH THAT
I WILL TURN IT OVER TO THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE. FOR THEIR
BRILLIANCE.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN UP
TO THREE MINUTES IN TOTAL FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
CASEY O'CONNOR LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR STATE TREASURER
FIONA MA.
I WAS THE TREASURES LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR AT THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION AS WELL AND THE
AGENCY HAD BEEN COLLECTING SALES
AND USE TAX PAYMENTS IN THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SIX UP
UNTIL RECENTLY ONE CD TFA TOOK
OVER THAT RESPONSIBILITY WHEN
ENTITIES WERE SPLIT -- UNLIKE
MOST BUSINESSES CANNABIS
BUSINESSES ARRIVE TO OUR
GOVERNMENT OFFICES WITH DUFFEL
BAGS FULL OF CASH TO FILL THEIR
TAX OBLIGATIONS STANDARD
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES LIKE AUDITS BECAME VERY
DIFFICULT FOR US WHEN MOST
TRANSACTIONS ARE COMPLETED IN
CASH.
CONDITIONALLY THESE BUSINESSES
FACE SECURITY RESTS BECAUSE OF
THE VOLUME OF CASH IN THEIR
POSSESSION SO WE SAW AND HEARD
FIRST HAND HORROR STORIES FROM
MEMBERS OF OUR BE A WE DISTRICT.
PEOPLE THAT WERE RUN OFF THE
ROADS ROBBED AT GUNPOINT BY ONLY
OVERTAKEN BECAUSE EVERYONE KNOWS
THIS INDUSTRY OPERATES IN CASH
THEY KNOW WHEN THEY'RE MAKING
THEIR TAX PAYMENTS.
AND THEY WOULD SHOW UP TO OUR
OFFICES IN TO BE PRETTY
DEVASTATING TO HEAR THE STORIES.
AND THE CHARGES WERE ACTIVELY
INVOLVED IN THIS -- PROCESS NOW
TO FIND A VIABLE WAY TO BANK THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY AND WE BELIEVE
SB FIFTY ONE IS A NECESSARY REAL
SOLUTION TO GET THE CASH OFF THE
STREETS NOW.
HEIGHTENED PUBLIC SAFETY AND
INCREASE THE TAX COLLECTION AND
TRANSPARENT AUDITING OF THE
MONIES IN THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY
INTO INCENTIVIZE COMPLIANCE I'LL
SEE THE REST OF MY TIME TO SEE
CA THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ANY FRANK
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATIONS
TO GIVE A QUICK INDUSTRY
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS -- AS THE
SENATOR MENTIONED -- ARE
COMPLAIN CANNABIS INDUSTRY
BRINGS IN MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
EACH QUARTER -- HOWEVER WE'VE
BEEN SHUT OUT OF THE MAKING
SUSHI -- SYSTEM THIS CREATES NOT
ONLY MONETARY ISSUES BUT SOME
SEVERE PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUES FOR
OUR MEMBERS AND EMPLOYEES -- TO
PUT THIS IN PERSPECTIVE WE HAVE
A MEMBER COMPANY THAT WAS FORCED
TO TRANSPORT UP TO MILLION
DOLLARS EACH MONTH IN CASH.
WHAT THIS TO THAT THAT CDFA
REGIONAL OFFICE IN SANTA ROSA
WHAT THIS MEANT WAS THAT THEY
SPEND ABOUT A MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY -- IN STAFFING AND
TRANSPORT FEES AND THAT'S NOT TO
MENTION THE FEES RELATED TO
CASHIERS CHECKS AND WHATNOT SO A
BIG MONETARY AND PUBLIC SAFETY
ISSUE ON INDUSTRY.
HIS OFFENSE ALSO FOR OURSELVES --
WE ACTUALLY IS THE ASSOCIATION
HAVE HAD.
BANKING ISSUES WE ACTUALLY
RECENTLY HAD OUR PACK ACCOUNT
SHUT DOWN SIMPLY BECAUSE THE
NAME CANNABIS IS IN IT -- SO
THIS IS AN EMBARRASSING AND
FRUSTRATING ISSUE FOR FOR US WHO
DOESN'T WE DON'T DEAL WITH ANY
SORT OF CANNABIS BUSINESS ITSELF
IT IS TO TRADE ASSOCIATION -- SO
FOR THESE REASONS AND MANY
OTHERS WERE IN PRAGUE TO PART OF
THIS BILL AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS FROM AN INDUSTRY
PERSPECTIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT NAY MANY AFFILIATION IF
YOU WISH TO DO SO.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
ANDREA DIVO ON BEHALF OF EASE
AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING DELYLAH CLAMBER
HAVE LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN
SUPPORT.
YOUR MEMBERS ROSS BUT THE ON
BEHALF OF SAVE SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHECK NINE MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ROSE IN A
GARAGE -- HEAR ME OUT OF THE
CITY OUT OF ALAMEDA ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING I'LL HANDLE SO
LEASE ON BEHALF OF UNITED KIND
OF THIS BUSINESS AND STE
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
HI SABRINA FANDRICH ON BEHALF OF
BERKELEY PATIENTS GROUP IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MAX BUT LOS ON
BEHALF OF FLOW CON AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
DESTINY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF ITS
C. B. D. AND I SUPPORT.
SIERRA VAN METER ON BEHALF OF
THAT CD AND I SUPPORT.
STANLEY WAY ON BEHALF OF THAT
CITY AND I SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
CNN NOW ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
AND MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU CAN KINDLY MAKE YOUR WAY
IT EXPEDITIOUSLY TO THIS.
TABLE HERE AND WILL ALSO PROVIDE
YOU UP TO THREE MINUTES IN TOTAL
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
MY NAME IS COME AGAIN I WAS NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THIS.
BILL UNTIL I HEARD HIM SPEAKING.
I'M A LICENSED PHYSICIAN AND
WHAT I'VE NOTICED IS -- WHAT THE
OPPOSITION IS COMING FROM IS --
FINANCIAL PERSPECTIVE OF THESE
TRANSACTIONS.
I MEAN IF YOU IF YOU LOOK AT THE
HISTORY OF CANNABIS HUNDRED
HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS AGO.
IT HAS.
IT HAS CHANGED THE WAY A MAN
THINKS.
I MET SOME DEGREE YOU HAVE TO
SEE THAT SOMETHING THAT AFFECTS
THE JUDGMENT HAS TO BE
CONTROLLED THAT'S WHY YOU HAD A
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE ACT.
AND THIS GOT OUT OF THAT.
I'M NOT TO BE ABLE TO BRACKET.
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION WILL PLAY
A ROLE AND I THINK OF THE
OPPOSITION COMES FROM THERE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AN
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE -- ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GIPSON THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS
WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR
LOOKING AT THIS FROM A VERY
INNOVATIVE -- LANDS WE
APPRECIATE IT IS CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT IS NEEDED IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE CANNABIS HERE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE.
OF THAT THE SAFETY RISK IS IN
FACT A DRESS AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE SAFETY ISSUE.
AND ALSO MAKING SURE THAT -- YOU
KNOW THE VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
SAY WE THEY WANTED SO WE WAS
HERE AS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE SAFE.
AND SECURE BY PROVIDING
TRANSACTIONS ARE SAFE -- I WOULD
LOVE TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF THE
BILL -- IF IT'S NOT TOO LATE --
NEVER TOO LATE WILL LOVE TO MOVE --
MOVED HIS BILL AT APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HAMMER GETS IN ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
SENATOR HERTZBERG YOU WISH TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THINK THE
TO I SAID ALL MY OPENING ANSWERS
BERKELEY ASK -- FOR AND I VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AGAIN WE WANT TO ALSO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF TO RECOGNIZE YOUR
TENACITY AND ALSO PARTNERSHIP
WITH TREASURE FEE ON A MIND
RECOGNIZING HOW WE CAN CONTINUE.
TO ADVANCE THE INTERESTS OF THE
REGULAR MARKET PLACE AND THIS IS
AGAIN ONE OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
DO SO AND WE ALSO JOIN YOU IN
YOUR COLLECTIVE EFFORT SO -- WE
WILL TAKE UP THIS ITEM -- WHEN
WE HAVE A STEPS A QUORUM THANK
YOU MISTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH?
THEN MOVING ON TO NEXT IN FILE
ORDER WHICH IS FILE NUMBER.
TWO SB ONE NINETY THREE BY
SENATOR NIELSEN.
CENTER IS A WELCOME GOOD MORNING
THIS CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
AND THIS CHAIRMAN PERMISSION TO
HAND OUT A A ARTICLE FROM THE
LOS ANGELES TIMES AND THEN A
PICTURE OF SOME OF THESE
CANISTERS.
PLEASE YES AND THEN WHILE YOU'RE
HANDLES OUT AYE IF YOU CAN KILEY
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO MANY
CENTER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
BROWN'S [inaudible]
BLOOM.
ARAMBULA.
CHEN.
CHIU CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN.
ALL GIPSON.
GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN IRWIN MCCARTY MEDINA
MULLIN OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE HERE TING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANDERSON
WE'VE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM.
THIS CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR TAKING TIME TO MEET WITH
ME AND YOUR STAFF WORKING WITH
MY OWN STAFF.
THIS BILL WAS BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION BY CONSTITUENTS WHO
HAVE SUFFERED UNDER THIS
PARTICULAR SITUATION WE'RE
TRYING HERE TO DEAL WITH IN
SMOKE SHOPS.
IT PROHIBITS RETAILERS OF
TOBACCO OR TOBACCO RELATED
PRODUCTS THESE ARE CALLED SMOKE
SHOP YOUR HEAD SHOPS.
FROM SELLING NITROUS OXIDE
CANISTERS.
NITROUS OXIDE HAS A USEFUL
PURPOSE IN A VERY CONTROLLED
CIRCUMSTANCE.
USED IN FOR EXAMPLE A DOCTOR'S
OFFICE.
BUT IT HAS A DANGEROUS USE AS
WELL.
THE CANISTERS ARE SOLD WITH THE
CRACKER WHICH IS A DEVICE USED
TO INGEST.
SMOKE.
AND THAT IS ADOPTED. TO BE ABLE
TO ATTACH THIS CANISTER.
WHICH THAT INDIVIDUAL CAN THEN
DIRECTLY INGEST.
THIS NITROUS OXIDE.
THE STREET NAME OF THIS IS WHAT.
IT'S USED TO INHALE THIS
DANGEROUS.
BUT ALTHOUGH HELPFUL.
JUST SOME UNDER SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES.
IN MANY CASES IT'S VERY
DANGEROUS AS A WITNESS WILL
SURELY INDICATE.
THEY'RE NOT COMMONLY KNOWN THESE
DANGERS.
AND THESE CANISTERS IN THE
ADAPTERS ARE VERY READILY
AVAILABLE THAT SMOKE SHOPS IT
PROLIFERATE IN ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND PEOPLE WHO GO WHEN THEY'RE
PROBABLY DON'T KNOW MOST OF THEM
DON'T KNOW.
THAT THESE CANISTERS ARE
AVAILABLE.
WHEN THEY BEGIN TO USE THE
NITROUS OXIDE THOUGH THEY DO
FIND [inaudible]
THE SUPPLY.
A VERY CONVENIENT [inaudible]
SUPPLY.
NOW THE INDIVIDUALS CAN.
ACCESS THESE CANISTERS FROM
OTHER SOURCES.
WE KNOW THAT.
BUT YOU CAN'T CUT OFF EVERY
SOURCE BUT MUCH THE GOAL OF THE
BILL IS.
SINCE THE SMOKE SHOPS ARE SO.
EVIDENT IN OUR COMMUNITIES. TO
SIMPLY MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT
[inaudible] FOR THEM.
PARTICULARLY OUR YOUTH. TO HAVE
ACCESS.
I AM INFORMED THAT THIS DOCTOR'S
OXIDE HIGH IS A VERY BRIEF HIGH.
AND IT REQUIRES CONTINUAL
NURTURING.
THE EXCESSIVE AMOUNTS THAT
INDIVIDUALS TAKE.
HAZARDS THEIR HEALTH.
ALL THE MORE.
IT REPLACES NIGHT NOT OXYGEN IN
THE BRAIN AND DAMAGES TO BRING.
INDIVIDUALS OF DIED.
AND BEEN CRIPPLED.
IT DOESN'T SHOW UP IN STANDARD
DRUG TESTS.
IT IS AFFECTING.
I BELIEVE A LOT OF OUR CITIZENS.
AND THE MOST VULNERABLE. ONE OF
MY STAFF.
WANTED TO HAVE A CHOIR.
THE CANISTER. TO SHOW IN
COMMITTEE.
SHE WENT TO THE HAVE.
A SMOKE SHOP.
AND REQUESTED A CANISTER.
AND I BELIEVE IT'S PERMISSION TO
SHOW THAT CANISTER MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
IT'S JUST A LITTLE GREEN THING
RIGHT HERE.
AND IT WAS INTERESTING.
THE PERSON JUST.
WIPED OUT A BOX.
AND IT ACROSS THE COUNTER.
SHE SAID DON'T YOU REQUIRE ANY
MORE INFORMATION. FOR ME
[inaudible]
NOW.
EXCEPT DON'T YOU WANT TO BUY
MORE.
DON'T YOU WANT TO BUY MORE.
WELL THAT'S TROUBLING BECAUSE
THAT INDIVIDUAL.
OBVIOUSLY WANTED TO SELL MORE.
BUT WHAT HE ALSO KNEW.
IS THAT PEOPLE HAVE.
A CHOIR AMPLE SUPPLIES OF THE
SAYING SO THEY CAN SUSTAIN.
THEY'RE VERY TEMPORARY HICE.
I'D LIKE.
TO INTRODUCE TO YOU TODAY MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS BARBARA
WATCH FOR SOME TESTIMONY.
RELATING HER VERY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE.
AND ONE THAT I FEAR FOR TOO MANY
OTHER [inaudible]
CALIFORNIANS.
AND AMERICANS.
ARE EXPERIENCING BARBARA THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR.
HI GOOD MORNING -- CAN YOU HEAR
ME YEAH.
MY NAME IS BARBARA LARGE I'M A
NATIVE OF LOS ANGELES LIVING IN
WEST LA.
I'M AN ATTORNEY A WRITER A
MOTHER OF TWO ADULT CHILDREN.
I AM HERE BECAUSE MY TWENTY FIVE
YEAR OLD SON SUSTAINED BRAIN
DAMAGE FROM A SEVERE ADDICTION
TO NITROUS OXIDE.
WHICH HE FED BY REGULARLY
PURCHASING HUNDREDS OF CANISTERS
FROM SMOKING TOBACCO SHOPS
ACROSS LA.
HUFFING OR INHALING NITROUS IS
ADDICTIVE AND BECAME MY SON'S
DRUG OF CHOICE.
WHILE HE RESIDED IN A SOBER
LIVING.
A ROOMMATE INTRODUCED IT TO HIM
AS A WELL KNOWN OPTION FOR THOSE
WHO WANT TO GET HIGH WITHOUT
GETTING CAUGHT.
ONCE KIDS IN SOBER LIVINGS ARE
ABLE TO LEAVE THE PREMISES.
MANY GO DIRECTLY TO LOCAL SMOKE
SHOPS TO BUY WEAPONS BECAUSE
THAT DRUG IS 1100% UNDETECTABLE
ON DRUG TESTS.
THESE KIDS CAN'T BUY IT ONLINE
OR HAVE IT DELIVERED BECAUSE ALL
DELIVERIES IN PACKAGES ARE
SEARCHED BY STAFF AT SOBER
LIVINGS OUR PARENTS.
SO THEIR ONLY OPTION IS TO GO
BUY THIS PRODUCT FACE TO FACE IN
THE STORES.
AND THIS SOON BECAME MY SON'S
DRUG OF CHOICE.
PEOPLE DESCRIBE THE HIGH FROM
HAVING NITROUS AS THIRTY SECONDS
OF ABSOLUTE BLISS.
WHAT THAT EUPHORIA REALLY IS
THOUGH IS BRAIN CELLS STARVING
FOR OXYGEN?
WHEN INHALED THE GAS DISPLACES
ALL OF THE ON ALL THE OXYGEN IN
THE LUNGS WHICH PRODUCES A
SUDDEN DEPRIVATION OF OXYGEN TO
THE BRAIN?
THIS CAN CAUSE NOT ONLY BRAIN
DAMAGE LIKE MY SON.
BUT ALSO STROKES PARALYSIS HEART
FAILURE AND DEATH FROM
ASPHYXIATION.
A GOOD FRIEND OF MINE LOST HER
BROTHER TO SUDDEN SNIFFING DEATH
FROM HAVING NITROUS OXIDE.
ON ONE OCCASION MY SON TURNED
BLUE AND HAD TO BE SLAPPED BACK
INTO CONSCIOUSNESS.
AND THIS IS IMPORTANT THE
DANGERS OF INHALING NITROUS
EXTEND TO NON USERS AS WELL.
MANY PEOPLE USE NITROUS AS SOON
AS THEY BY IT MOST OFTEN IN
PARKING LOTS BEHIND SMOKE SHOPS
AND EVEN WHILE DRIVING.
MY SON DESCRIBED THE ACTUAL
PARKING LOT BEHIND HIS FAVORITE
SMOKE SHOP AS BEING LITTERED
WITH SPENT CANISTERS AND
BALLOONS ALL OVER THE GROUND.
HE ALSO ADMITTED TO HUFFING
RIGHT THERE IN HIS CAR AND THEN
DRIVING OFF.
MOREOVER RECENT NEWS REPORTS AN
INCREASING NUMBER OF FATAL CAR
CRASHES WHERE THE DRIVERS HIGH
ON NITROUS PASSED OUT BEHIND THE
WHEEL. ONE SUCH FATAL TWENTY
NINETEEN ACCIDENT INVOLVED A
YOUNG MAN WHO DROVE HIS CAR
STRAIGHT INTO A FAMILY OF FOUR
WALKING ON THE SIDEWALK.
POLICE FOUND TWELVE USED
CANISTERS OF NITROUS OXIDE
INSIDE HIS DUFFEL BAG.
A LONG WITH THEIR PURCHASE
RECEIPT FROM A SMOKE SHOP.
I RECENTLY PAID A LOCAL A VISIT
TO MY LOCAL SMOKE SHOP TO SEE
FOR MYSELF HOW EASY IT IS TO BUY
THIS DRIVE AND HOW OWNERS AND
EMPLOYEES FREELY SELL IT WITHOUT
REGARD TO CONSEQUENCES.
I'M GIVING A PARTY I LIED TO THE
SALES PERSON DO YOU HAVE
SOMETHING CALLED WITH ITS.
HE POINTED TO A PLASTIC TUB
BRIMMING WITH VIBRANT COLORED
BALLOONS BOOKENDED BY BOXES OF
WEAPONS.
I SAW MANY DIFFERENT BRANDS SUCH
AS SPECIAL BLUE MARKETED BY AN
ANGRY FIRE BREATHING DRAGON.
HERE'SA MATCHING DRAGON ON THIS
THE CRACKER HERE.
AND RADHIKA BRAND BOASTING A
TOPLESS WOMAN WITH DOLLOPS OF
WHIPPED CREAM ON HER BREASTS.
THEN OF COURSE IN THE SMOKE SHOP
THERE WAS THE ORIGINAL WHIPPET
FEATURING A HAPPY HOMEMAKER FOR
SHOWING OFFER DISPENSER.
IN DRUG PARLANCE FOR CRACKER.
ALL ALONG SIDE VAPE PENS VAPE DO
CIGARETTES AND CANDIES.
WHY WOULDN'T AN INDIVIDUAL
COMING IN TO JUST BUY CIGARETTES
THE ATTRACTED TO THESE
DISTINCTIVE DISPLAYS?
AND CONVINCE HIMSELF
SPONTANEOUSLY CAN'T HURT TO TRY.
IF YOU COULD KINDLY WRAP UP WITH
REACHING FOR MINUTES.
SORRY REACHING FOUR MINUTES IF
YOU COULD KINDLY WRAP YOUR
TESTIMONY OKAY.
HOME OKAY ALTHOUGH MY SON HAS
SINCE COMMITTED TO A LIFE OF
SOBRIETY THE TRUTH IS ON ANY DAY
OR NIGHT HE CAN WALK INTO ANY
SMOKE SHOP. TO BUY VAPE USES
SUDDENLY FIND HIMSELF FACE TO
FACE WITH EVERYTHING HE NEEDS TO
RESUME HIS DEADLY ADDICTION TO
NITROUS OXIDE.
HE CAN EVEN SMELL THE ROBBERY
LOWER OF THE BALLOONS WHICH IS
INDEED TRIGGERING TO HAVE.
IT WOULD BE LOGICAL FOR AIRPLANE
GLUE PAINT THINNER AND THEIR
ASSOCIATES YOU VERY MUCH CAN I
JUST FINISH IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND FOR JOINING US
HERE TODAY IN THE STATE CAPITAL
ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
CNN ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME.
SENIOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
DOCTOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- I GUESS
MY MY QUESTION IS.
HAS BEEN AS ONE OF THE HEAD.
YOU OF SAID RECENT FROM
FREQUENTLY WE MAKE IT HARD IN
CALIFORNIA FOR SMALL BUSINESS --
TO TO TO MAKE IT -- IN LOVE THE
SMALL PIECE IN OFFICE SMOKE
SHOPS ARE MOM AND POP SHOPS --
SO THE SO THIS IS A LEGAL
SOMETHING THAT IS SOLD.
AND I GUESS MY QUESTION IS
BECAUSE I JUST SAT HERE AND
LOOKED IT UP.
ON AMAZON.
A AND I CAN HAVE THEM DELIVERED
TO MY DOOR -- WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS FOR TWENTY TWO NINETY NINE
A PACK OF FIFTY SO IF WE BAN
THEM.
FROM BEING SOLD IN STORES.
ISN'T ISN'T JUST IN THE EASIER
THING TO DO FOR PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO ORDER THEM ONLINE AND
HAVE THE SAME.
EASY ACCESS.
WELL FIRST OF ALL THOSE COULD
NOT THEN GO TO ANYONE WHO WAS IN
A TREATMENT FACILITY IS A
WITNESS TO TESTIFY.
BUT THAT SAID.
YES.
THEY COULD GO ONLINE. ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS SO MANY THINGS THAT YOU
CAN GET ONLINE THAT CAN BE VERY
HARMFUL.
MY POINT IN THIS IS SIMPLY TO
MAKE IT LESS AVAILABLE.
AND LESS AVAILABLE MEANS IN
SMOKE SHOPS.
THAT'S A SIMPLE FORMULA TO MAKE
IT LESS AVAILABLE.
MAKE THE NITROUS OXIDE LESS
AVAILABLE.
AND HOPEFULLY WAY PRESENTING
THIS BILL AND INFORMATION AS WE
HAVE TO THE COURSE OF CARRYING
THIS BILL.
INCREASE THE AWARENESS.
OF FAMILIES BEEN VEGETABLES.
OF THE DANGERS.
OF NITROUS OXIDE.
IT'S KIND OF A STEALTH.
AFFLICTION RIGHT NOW AND THE
PEOPLE KNOW MORE ABOUT IT.
WE BELIEVE.
THERE WILL BE LESS OF IT USED.
MAY I ADD MAN I IS IT POSSIBLE
TO ADD NO NOT NOT AT THIS TIME
UNLESS IS A CRESCENT DIRECTLY
AND MADE. TO HER QUESTION NO NO
IT IN LESS THAT'S OKAY YEAH
THERE IS.
NO NOT AT THIS TIME ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME [inaudible]
MR BLOOM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- A
SENATOR NIELSEN I I WANT.
TO THANK YOU FOR CONTINUING TO
CALL ATTENTION -- TO THIS ISSUE --
I'VE I BELIEVE IT'S ONE OF MANY
INVOLVING SUBSTANCE ABUSE TO
THAT ARE OUT THERE AND I THINK --
FRANKLY -- WITH -- OF MOST OF
THE CATEGORIES OF SUBSTANCES
THAT ARE OUT THERE -- THAT ARE
BEING ABUSED.
WE'RE FIGHTING INCREMENTAL
BATTLES.
AND I'M NOT SURE IF THIS
ULTIMATELY IS THE SOLUTION.
BUT AS YOU POINT OUT I THINK IT
MAKES -- AND WOULD MAKE AN
INCREMENTAL DIFFERENCE -- THERE
HAS TO BE SOME WAY OF CALLING
ATTENTION PARTICULARLY THE YOUNG
PEOPLE OF THE DANGERS OF THIS
OTHERWISE SEEMINGLY.
INNOCENT.
PRACTICE AND AND YOU KNOW I
DON'T THINK HERE BILLS A PANACEA
I DON'T THINK YOU THINK IT'S
BASS EITHER -- BUT IT ISN'T AN
INCREMENTAL STEP IN A SUPPORT.
IT WAS AN EYE OPENER ASSEMBLYMAN
WHEN.
BARBARA BROADER SON.
AND I GOT TO SEE THE IMPACT ON
ONE HUMAN BEING.
THAT WAS SUFFICIENT.
TO WHAT MY INTEREST AND PASSION
ON THE SUBJECT MATTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME.
AND SEEING NONE THEN SEVEN IS A
MAY I ASK YOU A SPECIFICALLY
WITH REFERENCE TO THE COMMITTEE
NOW SAYS ON THE NOTION THAT IF
WE OF THEN HELP SUPPORT.
SOME OF THESE PURCHASES TO THE
NON.
LICENSE -- ESTABLISHMENTS YEAH
THIS IS IN TOBACCO SHOPS AND
TOBACCO SHOPS AND ARE REGULATED
MORE HEAVILY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND SO THE QUESTION
OF THE THOUGHT BEHIND
INDIVIDUALS THEN GOING ELSEWHERE
AND LESS REGULATED ENVIRONMENTS --
COULD THAT BE A CHALLENGE FOR US
TO REALLY TACKLE THIS ISSUE I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAD ANY
COMMENTS WITH RESPECT THAT.
WELL I THINK I DID COMMON THIS
GERMAN JUST A BIT AGO.
CERTAIN.
IT'S AS EASY AS THE INTERNET.
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT. TO
MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT.
AND IT'S AN ARGUABLE THAT THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR SUN.
WHAT THEY THEN SEEK OTHER
SOURCES SURE?
BUT WE ALSO HAD THE ADDITIONAL
VALUE OF GETTING MORE PEOPLE
UNDERSTANDING.
OF THE QUICK THE AVAILABILITY.
IN OUR COMMUNITY EACH OF THIS.
HOPEFULLY THEN TO DISCOURAGE
THEM FROM GOING TO INTERNET AND
OR BLACK MARKET SOURCES.
YOU BET YOU NEVER STOP THE BLACK
MARKET SOURCES FOR WHATEVER.
IT WILL BE THERE.
BUT WE'RE TRYING TO IMPROVE AND
INCREASE [inaudible]
PUBLIC AWARENESS.
OF SOMETHING THAT IS VERY
DANGEROUS. TO OUR SOCIETY.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND NIELSEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
WELL MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
FOR CONSIDERING IT.
I HAVE HAD NO OPPOSITION AS
WE'VE PROGRESSED THIS BILL SO
FAR THROUGH THE PROCESS.
SO IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THERE WAS
SOME ACCEPTANCE OF OUR ARGUMENTS.
AND THE NEAT.
I WOULD REQUEST.
A MOTION A SECOND AND THEN I
WILL.
SOARED CAVEAT THERE'S BEEN AN
MOTION AND A SECOND RESISTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB ONE NINETY THREE MOTIONS THE
PASTOR PREPARATIONS Là NO NO NO
BRO.
BROUGH AYE ARAMBULA [inaudible]
REMEMBERING [inaudible]
BLOOM.
MY CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EVEN NOW FONG FONG AYE GIPSON
[inaudible]
GLORIA GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
THAT CON HAS FIVE OWES BELIEVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
FOLLOW THE WAR.
KATIE THIS A BIT AND BEEN A
MOTIONS OF FOR A FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE SENATOR FIRST BREAK
THIS INTO IS IT DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. FOR THE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB FIFTY ONE MOTIONS YOU PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS LOW LOW AYE BRO.
I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I BLOOM THEM
I CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN.
I CAN I FONG.
I'M NOT VOTING GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
THE BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES AND
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
AND MEMBERS WE ARE NOW JUST
CURRENTLY WAITING FOR ADDITIONAL
AUTHORS AND I KNOW THAT THE
SERGEANTS ARE CALLING AT TODAY
IS A BUSY DAY AS I WE UNDERSTAND.
SO WILL KINDLY WAIT PATIENTLY
FOR ADDITIONAL AUTHORS
[inaudible]
THIS IS [inaudible]
LEGISLATURE
--
THE WE'LL NOW
MOVE ON THEN. TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS SB THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
REQUIRES AN ACQUIRED THIS DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
HEY ITEMS CHAIR IN A MEMBERS --
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THIS.
I'LL BE QUICK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING
US TO BE HERE TODAY JENNIFER
CMOS WITH US -- FROM THE MEDICAL
BOARD AS WELL AS BE THREE SEVEN
SEVEN WILL CUT THROUGH THE RED
TAPE AND FINALLY ALLOW THE
MEDICAL BOARD TO GET ACCESS. TO
THE INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
CONFIDENTIALLY INVESTIGATE --
OVER PRESCRIBING PATTERNS -- BY
GRANTING AUTHORIZATION WHEN THE
MEDICATION IS AUTHORIZED BY THE
COURTS TO FOSTER USE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA -- OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH ALL SIDES ON THE
SOLUTION AND WE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL THANKS TO THE CHAIR OF
THE COMMITTEE STAFF -- HAPPENED
SURE THAT DEMEANS TAKEN THE LAST
COMING HERE REMOVE OPPOSITION
FROM THE CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN THE CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION THIS IS BEEN.
A THREE YEAR ENDEAVOR NOW -- AND
WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL FOR ALL OF
YOUR WORK MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP IN
THIS YOU WANT TO SAY THANK YOU I
TO MISS THE MOST WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I BOTH.
JENNIFER CMOS OF THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA JUST QUICKLY
THE POOR LIKE TO THINK CENTER
REQUIRE PERSISTENT ABOARD AND
OVERCOMING THE OBSTACLES THE
BOARD IS CURRENTLY FACING AND
OBTAIN AUTHORIZATIONS FOR
MEDICAL RECORDS FOR FOSTER YOUTH.
THE WAR NEEDS IS AUTHORIZATIONS
TO LOOK INTO THESE CASES MORE
STAFF AND DOES HAVE A SMALL
CONCERN WITH ONE OF THE
TECHNICAL AND AMENDMENTS TAKEN
LAST COMMITTEE BUT WE'RE WORKING
WITH AND WHY AND WE WILL WE'RE
FAIRLY SURE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
WORK THAT OUT SO.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES A MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT NAY MANIPULATION IF
YOU WISH TO DO SO.
HI ANDY WE EVEN BOND WE HAVE FOR
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND WHILE
MUCH OF THE BILLS OUT OF OUR
PURVIEW WE JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK OF THE
SENATOR AND TAKING AS MANY
AMENDMENTS AND MAKING THE BILL
POSSIBLE SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
CNN ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION.
YES GIVE MEMBERS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
KIND OF PREVIOUSLY IN OPPOSITION
MAKING ALL RIGHT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION WITH THE AMENDMENTS --
WE ONE JUST THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING WITH US AND WITH THE
AMENDMENTS WERE MOVING
OPPOSITION.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RENTAL HAGER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION THE SAME GOES FOR US
WE ARE REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION
WITH THE RECENT AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NONE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COULD BE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME.
SEEN NO QUESTIONS ARE COMMON
SENATOR PROVIDE YOU WISH TO
CLOSE THANK YOU SO MUCH AS CHAIR
IS JOSE THINKING THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AS WELL FOR WORKING WITH
US WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
I PO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
WHERE THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND
SECOND ME SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SB THREE SEVENTY SEVEN MOTIONS
DO PASTOR PREPARATIONS LOW HIGH
WELL I BROKE.
MY REGULAR REMAIN AYE BLOOM.
THEN I CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GRAYSON.
HOLDEN IRWIN MCCARTY MEDINA
MULLIN OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE
TING.
THE BILL HAS NINE VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A NUMBER OF OUR WITH
THEM MOVE ON THEN -- TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN WHICH IS SB
SIX TWENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
GALGIANI [inaudible]
SENATOR WELCOME.
MISTER CHAIR I MEMBERS SB SIX
TWENTY SEVEN PROVIDES
VETERINARIANS OPPORTUNITY TO
RECOMMEND THE USE OF CANNABIS
PRODUCTS FOR MEDICINAL USE ON
THEIR ANIMAL PATIENTS.
PADS OUR FURRY FRIENDS SUFFER
FROM MANY OF THE SAME IF NOT
SIMILAR ELEMENTS THAT HUMANS DO.
AND WHICH MEDICAL CANNABIS
PRODUCTS HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO HAVE
A THERAPEUTIC BENEFIT.
SINCE VETERINARIANS ARE
CURRENTLY LIMITED ON HOW THEY
CAN DISCUSS THE USE OF MEDICAL
CANNABIS PRODUCTS LET ALONE
PROVIDE ANY RECOMMENDATIONS ON
DOSAGE OR APPLICATION OF
CANNABIS PRODUCTS.
PET OWNERS WOULD LIKE TO TREAT
THEIR ANIMALS OFTEN TO TURN TO
THE INTERNET FOR ADVICE OR
SIMPLY SEEK THE COUNSEL OF THE
RETAIL CANNABIS CLERK.
BEHIND THE COUNTER FOR
RECOMMENDATIONS RATHER THAN
GETTING THE ADVICE AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE MOST
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUAL THEIR LOCAL
VETERINARIAN.
PET OWNERS ARE AND INTENTIONALLY
PUTTING THEIR PETS HEALTH AND
SAFETY IN DANGER.
ANIMAL CANADA.
CANNABINOID RECEPTORS SYSTEMS
ARE DIFFERENT FROM HUMANS SO
DOSAGES MUST BE ADJUSTED FOR THE
TYPE OF ANIMAL ITS WEIGHT AND
OBVIOUSLY THE CONDITION YOU ARE
TRYING TO ADDRESS.
IN AN EFFORT TO PROTECT ANIMALS
PROVIDE FOR THE SAFE USE OF
CANNABIS PRODUCTS AND TO ALLOW
THOSE VETERINARIANS WHO WISH TO
MAKE A RECOMMENDATION.
ON CANNABIS USE I'VE AUTHORED SB
SIX TWENTY SEVEN MY STAFF HAS
WORKED WITH COMMITTEE STAFF ON A
NUMBER OF CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS
WHICH ARE LISTED IN THE ANALYSIS.
CERTAINLY WE'VE MADE GREAT
PROGRESS ALONG WITH TOP TOUGH
COMPROMISES ON THIS MEASURE AND
I APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT WENT
INTO THIS EFFORT AND ALL THE
WORK WITH THE KIDS COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS AS WELL.
THEREFORE I WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND
WITH ME TODAY. TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT I HAVE PAUL HANSBERRY
AND SUSAN TIBBON FROM LOVINGLY
AND LEGALLY WHO SPONSORED THIS
LEGISLATION AND ARE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS REGARDING
THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND UP TO
THREE MINUTES IN TOTAL FOR
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT SO FEEL
FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
HI PAUL HANDS VERY LOVINGLY
LEGALLY -- FOR A VERY LONG TIME --
WE'VE -- BEEN.
ADVOCATING FOR THE THE
VETERINARIANS TO BE ABLE TO
SAFELY RECOMMEND CANNABIS FOR
THEIR AMIL PATIENTS.
OF AS FAR AS THE THE MEDICINE
THAT THEY WERE REQUIRED TO GIVE
THE VETERINARIANS THE TOOLS THEY
NEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SUSAN TEVIN.
WE APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND STAFF AND WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE VICTORY
PROFESSION.
AND THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
ANIMALS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO STATE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH
TO DO SO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CRISTINA TO CAR
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU
COMMITTEE VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND YOUR CONSULT MISFIRES AND OF
COURSE SENATOR GALGIANI AND HER
STAFF.
A WITH THE AGREEMENT TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS
SPECIFICALLY ONE THREE SEVEN AND
NINE THROUGH ELEVEN THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION AND MOVE TO A SUPPORT
AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AMENDMENT
NUMBER EIGHT WHICH I KNOW HAS
BEEN THE SUBJECT OF MUCH
DISCUSSION TO AND I COULD HAVE
DONE A BETTER JOB OF THAT MY
LETTER SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI GET A GOOD MORNING MAX THE
CLUELESS ON BEHALF OF THAT CD
WERE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE BILL
WITH THAT MA'AM AND SEVEN TAKEN
IN CLEAN AMENDMENT EIGHT THAT
PROVIDES FOR ACCESS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS SIERRA I AM A
RESIDENT OF SAN PUBLIC HEALTH
FORMULA I AM ALSO WITH THAT CD
AND I SUPPORT THE AMENDMENTS.
HELLO MY NAME IS JESSE MARTIN
I'M A RESIDENT OF LEO CALIFORNIA
AND I SUPPORT THE AMENDMENTS I
USE THAT TO BE FROM MY ANIMAL AS
WELL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S NICOLE
RUNNING AND FROM SACRAMENTO AND
I WORK FOR THAT CBD AND I
SUPPORT -- WITH THE AMENDMENTS.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINE'S
VERSION I LIVE IN YOLO COUNTY
AND I USE THAT CVD I SUPPORT THE
AMENDMENT FOR MY DOG SHE HAS
ANXIETY.
AND SEPARATION ISSUES.
IT'S VERY BENEFICIAL AND THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ALICIA KEEP AN EYE
SUPPORT BETSY REEDY.
I USE IT ON MY CATS.
HE GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
STANLEY OR EVEN I'M A RESIDENT
OPEN KIND OF OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
AND I SUPPORT THE AMENDMENTS.
SABRINA FREDERICK ON BEHALF OF
BERKELEY PATIENTS GROUP IN
SUPPORT OF THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME.
SEE NONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE HULK
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO
THE TABLE AND WILL PROVIDE UP TO
THREE MINUTES. FOR TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION.
MORNING MY NAME IS JUST.
EXECUTIVE OFFICE OF THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
BOARD.
AND WE OPPOSE SB SIX TO SEVEN WE
DID OPPOSE IT BACK IN APRIL FOR
THE VERY REASONS IDENTIFIED IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
TAKING MANY OTHER MOMENTS BUT
SOME OF OUR CONCERNS STILL STAND.
AND I WANTED THE AUTHORS OFFICE
THE BOARDING KNOWLEDGE THAT
CANNABIS AND CANVAS PRODUCTS MAY
HAVE POTENTIAL HEALTH BENEFITS
ANIMALS.
HOWEVER THERE ARE STILL
SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR FUNDING FOR
CAMPUS RESEARCH SO THAT AN AREA
AND AND THE PUBLIC ARE INFORMED
ON THE POSSIBLE EFFECTIVE USE OF
CANNABIS TO TREAT ANIMALS.
AND ENSURE THE FULL PROTECTION
OF CONSUMERS AND THEIR ANIMALS.
MOTHER MEDICATIONS AND LEADERS
TRUCKS HAVE BEEN PROVIDED TO
ANIMAL PATIENTS WITHOUT
SIGNIFICANT RESEARCH.
THOSE WERE NOT PREVIOUSLY
IDENTIFIED AS SCHEDULED ONE
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE ****
CANNABIS.
IN ADDITION THERE SEEMS TO BE A
MUST COME TO THE MENTOR MEDICAL
FOR CAN DEVELOP GUIDELINES IS
THE WAY THE MEDICAL BOARD
CALIFORNIA DEVELOPED THERE.
HOWEVER BY THE TIME THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA WAS REQUIRED
TO DEVELOP THEIR GUIDELINES.
CMC ARE ALREADY HAD OVER A
DECADE'S WORTH OF RESEARCH ON
THE EFFICACY OF CANNABIS IN
HUMANS AND NBC WAS ABLE TO RELY
HEAVILY ON AND NEAR THE MAJORITY
OF THE GUIDELINES ALREADY
DEVELOPED.
BY THEIR NATIONAL ASSOCIATION BY
OF REGULATORY BOARDS.
THAT WOULD NOT BE THE CASE FOR
OUR BOARD.
AS THE THE COMMITTEE NOW SAYS
THE MC ARE HAS PERFORMED NO
RESEARCH ON THE EFFICACY OF
CANNABIS FOR ANIMALS AND OUR
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION RENTAL FOR
HAVE NO SUCH GUIDELINES TO RELY
ON IN FACT THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION BATTERIES THE BOARD
MEETING OF SIXTY TWO
JURISDICTIONS.
INCLUDING ALL THE UNITED STATES
AND OTHER COUNTRIES IS RELYING
ON OUR BOARD STRAPPED GUIDELINES
FOR DISCUSSING CANNABIS.
AB SB WOULD CERTAINLY FOLLOW OUR
LEAD ON GUIDELINES FOR
RECOMMENDED CANNABIS.
IF THIS BILL IS PASSED IN THE
PORT IS PORT OR SORRY.
IF THE BILL IS PASSED IN THE IN
IS FORCED TO DRAFT GUIDELINES
FOR RECOMMENDED CANNABIS WITHOUT
ANY RESEARCHER MEANINGFUL
ASSISTANCE PLEASE CONSIDER THE
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES THIS WILL
HAVE ON ANIMALS.
AND DINNER IS A CALIFORNIA THIS
NATION AND THE SUBSEQUENT
COUNTRIES TO FOLLOW.
RESEARCH MUST BE DONE AND
NECESSARY FUNDS MUST BE PROVIDED
IT IS ONLY THEN THAT THE SPORT
CAN DEVELOP EFFECTIVE AND
MEANINGFUL GUIDELINES FOR
DEPENDENT MEANS TO USE WOULD
RECOMMEND CANNABIS BUT ANIMAL
PATIENTS. FOR THESE REASONS WE
ARE JOURNAL ABOUT THANK YOU.
CONDITIONALLY THIS IS AN UP MY
NAME IS GOING TO GET ON THE FOR
THE PHYSICIAN FROM FRESNO
CALIFORNIA AND I'M WORRIED ABOUT
THE FISCAL IMPACT IT WILL HAVE
ON THE STATE.
IT ESSENTIALLY WOULD DONE THE
STATE BANKRUPT IN ORDER TO SET
UP THEIR OWN BE A FOR VETERINARY
SPECIES. TO CHECK THE DIVERSION
INTO THE HUMAN SPECIES.
SO THAT'S SOMETHING TO LOOK INTO
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE NOW QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME.
SEEING THAT THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
SENATOR GALGIANI DO YOU WISH TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
ARRIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I DOUBT IT AND AS YOU HAVE
STATED EARLIER THAT YOU.
ARE AGREEABLE TO THE FULL
COMMITTEE AND MEN'S AS PROPOSED
AS WELL YES I AM WE ARE TAKING.
WONDERFUL AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR WORKING COLLABORATIVELY
A WITH US THIS DOES ENJOY A TO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WE NEED. TO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND COMMITTEE SECTOR WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB SIX TWENTY SEVEN MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW.
THE I. BRO.
BRIAN ARAMBULA REVIEW AYE BLOOM.
THEN MY CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
FONG I GIPSON GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
OBERNOLTE.
RELIGION NOW TING.
THE BILL HAS NINE BOTH BELIEVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
GALGIANI WILL NOW MOVE ON THEN
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
WHICH IS SB SIX NINETY SEVEN BY
SENATOR CABALLERO.
CENTER TO COVER YOUR THIS DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE.
PLEASE FEEL FREE PRESENT WHEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MISTER
CHARLES GOING TO ASK IF I COULD
USE A PROP TO I THINK IT JUST
REALLY UNFAIR. TO ALLOW SENATOR
GALGIANI TO BRING A FAMILY
MEMBER.
SO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
SB SIX NINETY SEVEN WHICH WILL
MODERNIZE THE PHYSICIAN ASSISTED
PRACTICE. TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE SERVICES IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS AND BEFORE I
BEGIN I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL THEIR HARD
WORK.
ON ON THE AMENDMENTS WHICH YOU
WILL BE ACCEPTING TODAY.
SO IT'S NO SURPRISE THAT -- WE
HAVE A SHORTAGE OF HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS AND THE THIS
SHORTFALL.
IS GOING TO BECOME SIGNIFICANTLY
ACUTE OVER THE NEXT FIFTEEN
YEARS IN PARTICULAR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY CENTRAL COAST AND
SOUTHERN BORDER AREAS -- BECAUSE
OF THIS ON IN AN EVEN
DISTRIBUTION OF OF HEALTH CARE --
WE'RE WE'RE FINDING THAT --
THERE'S A REAL LACK OF
CLINICIANS THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
US TO USE PHYSICIAN'S ASSISTANTS
WITHIN THE SCOPE OF THEIR
PRACTICE -- AND IT'S WE'VE HAD A
VERY ROBUST -- STAKEHOLDERS
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS AND WE'VE
TAKEN SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE --
PROTECTING THE THE PUBLIC WE
HAVE GOOD CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
ALSO THAT THAT PHYSICIANS
ASSISTANCE CAN WORK WITHIN THEIR
SCOPE AND AND THAT THE DOCTORS
AND THEIR SUPERVISORS ARE IN
AGREEMENT AS WELL AND SO.
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE BUT TODAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IN A TO THREE
MINUTES IN TOTAL FOR WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT PLEASE FEEL FREE 2%
WHENEVER READY.
I CHAIR LOW AND MEMBERS OF MY
NAME IS THAT P. A. JEREMY EITHER
I'VE BEEN IN PRACTICE FOR TWENTY
YEARS.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE BILL'S
SPONSOR THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY
OF P. IS WHO REPRESENT OVER
TWELVE THOUSAND PH HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
HIS PRACTICE MEDICINE WITH
POSITIONS IN EVERY AREA.
THEY ARE HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF
DELIVERING EVIDENCE BASED HIGH
QUALITY CARE.
BOTH -- PA'S AND OUR POSITION
PARTNERS AT CMA BELIEVE ONE OF
THE WAYS TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
QUALITY HEALTHCARE IS TO
UNBURDEN SOME OF THE TOP DOWN
MICRO MANAGING STATE IMPOSE
STATUTE IMPOSED.
ADMINISTRATIVE ASPECTS OF PA
PRACTICE AND THIS THEN WILL
ALLOW PIECE IN POSITIONS TO
COLLABORATE TOGETHER AND BETTER
SERVE PATIENTS.
AS A CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION HAS SAID CALIFORNIA
PLACES RESTRICTIONS ON PA
PRACTICE CREATING BARRIERS TO
GROWTH IN TEAM BASED EFFICIENT
CARE.
SB SIX NINE SEVEN OVERCOMES MANY
OF THESE BARRIERS.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE AUTHOR
AND KAPPA WE WORKED WITH THEIR
STAKEHOLDERS -- THERE'S BEEN
MANY AMENDMENTS -- TAKEN OR
PLEASE CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION IF THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
ON BEHALF OF THE PAC WANT TO BE
ABLE TO BETTER PARTNER WITH
PHYSICIANS TO PROVIDE YOUR
CONSTITUENTS THE CARE THEY NEED.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS MAKING
ALL RIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL.
SIX NINE SEVEN OVER THE PAST
MONTHS WE WORKED CLOSELY WITH
THE AUTHOR PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT
ASSOCIATION STAKEHOLDERS AND
COMMITTEES. TO ENSURE THAT THIS
BILL ACCOMPLISHES THE GOALS THAT
WE SET OUT TO ACCOMPLISH NAMELY
THIS BILL WILL PUT PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANTS IN A PLACE WHERE
THEY'RE JUST AS EASY TO WORK
WITH.
AS NURSE PRACTITIONERS CREATING.
INCREASED ACCESS TO CALIFORNIANS
WHILE ENSURING PUBLIC SAFETY AND
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT -- WE
THINK EVERYBODY FOR ALL THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL AND ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
AT HOWARD ON BEHALF OF THE
SPONSOR CAPITALIST ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE BEEN
THINKING THAT COMMITTEE STAFFER
IT'S EXCELLENT WORK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RANDALL HAGER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION WE STRONGLY COMMEND
THIS BILL TO YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
I AM DOCTOR DESCRIBE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT.
AMBER CAM WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT.
JENNIFER SOMOS WITH THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT CNN NOW CALLING
UP ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE FEEL FREE.
TO COME TO THE TABLE.
AGAIN WILL PROVIDE.
NO MORE THAN THREE MINUTES IN
TOTAL FOR WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
MY NAME IS CAMERA GIL.
I AM FIRST TO FALL I'M A
PHYSICIAN FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIA
AND I AGREE WITH HER IN IN TERMS
OF THE MATTER DISTRIBUTION OF
THE THE POSITION WORK FORCE.
AND WE REALLY NEEDED BUT THIS
BILL HIDE INITIALLY SAID SIX
YEARS CAN BE SUPERVISED BY
POSITION I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
HAGGLING HAPPEN THAT NUMBER WAS
REDUCED.
TO FOUR AT SOME POINT.
SO I THINK THE NUMBER SHOULD BE
CHANGED FOR BASED ON THE NEED IN
THE VALLEY WE NEED MORE BE IS TO
BE THERE THE NUMBER SHOULD BE
CHANGED BACK. TO SIX THE SECOND
THING I WANT TO TELL THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IS TO LOOK AT
AB THREE FROM TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
AND CONTRAST THIS BILL WITH THAT.
BECAUSE AB TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
CREATED AN OPIATE CRISIS IN THIS
STATE.
THEY'RE A BUNCH OF OTHER OF
PROVISIONS I WOULD WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE RETROACTIVE --
AFFECTED PROVISIONS IN SECTION
JACKSON FIVE HAVE NOT BEEN
DELETED YET THOUGHT AMENDED TO
REFLECT THAT THE VIOLATIONS OF
THE EXISTING LAW IN EFFECT UNTIL
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WILL BE IN
FOR SUPPORTER EXISTING LAWS.
THAT IS BASED IN LINE FIFTEEN TO
SIXTEEN PAGE.
TEN LINE FORTY TWO PAGE ELEVEN
LING.
TO THE REFERENCE TO PRACTICE
ADMINISTRATORS HAS NOT BEEN
REMOVED CLARIFIED AMENDED TO
REFLECT RESTRICTIONS ON
UNLICENSED PRACTICE
ADMINISTRATORS WHICH REMAIN MY
GREATEST WORRY PAGE FIVE LINE.
TWENTY TWO TO TWENTY FOUR
LANGUAGE ADDITIONS TO REFLECT IN
THE AMENDMENT FOR BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS.
CODE -- TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED AT
THE END OF PARAGRAPH ARE
INSUFFICIENT BECAUSE THESE C<c.cyan> --</c>
PRACTICE SEGMENTS ARE LIKELY TO
BE DRAFTED BY UNLESS UNLICENSED
PERSON AND ENFORCED BY
UNLICENSED PERSON.
ON THEN THE SUPERVISING
PHYSICIAN WHO IS ACTUALLY THE
GUY DESIGNATED TO SUPERVISE THE
P. IT SHOULD HAVE SOME DEGREE OF
SAFETY AND DROPPING ORDER
AMENDING THE CONTENT OF THE
LANGUAGE OF THE PRACTICE.
AGREEMENT IF HE SO DESIRES
WITHIN THE PROVISIONS OF SECTION
FIVE BEGINNING THREE FIVE ZERO
TWO POINT THREE BUT SPECIFICALLY
PAGE.
NINE LINES THIRTY SIX TO FORTY
AND PAGE TEN LINES.
ELEVEN TO FOURTEEN POSITION
ASSISTANT MUST AND I'D BUY
UNDERSCORED THAT TOWARD POSITION
ASSISTANT MUST BE DESIGNATED AS
AN AGENT.
OF THE SUPERVISING PHYSICIAN.
PAGE TEN LINE EIGHTEEN TO
NINETEEN THANK YOU.
YOU MAY WISH TO SUMMARIZE DR.
NO DO YOU WISH TO SUMMARIZE YOUR
COMMENTS BECAUSE WE HAVE OTHER
IT WHEN THE SUSPICION TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION THIS AMENDMENT
WOULD CLEAR THE EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TALK TO GO
AND BECAUSE OF THAT WE WAS HE
TALKED TO US BEING COMING UP IN.
A NUMBER OF OTHER BILLS WILL
PROVIDE A TESTIMONY FOR THE
BOARD AND OTHERS TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SO -- PLEASE FEEL
FREE PRESENT WHEN YOU'RE READY.
AB MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TIM AND
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMEND A POSITION
WE JUST WANT TO THANK.
THE AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS FOR
THEIR TIME AND LISTENING TO OUR
CONCERNS OUR CONCERNS ARE
CENTERED AROUND.
ENSURING THAT THE PHYSICIAN AND
SUPERVISING THE PA HAS THE SAME
PRIVILEGES TO BE IN THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT OUR CONCERN
IS A POTENTIALLY COULD HAVE A
PHYSICIAN.
WHO IS SUPERVISING A PA IN THE
MERCY DEPARTMENT -- WHO DOESN'T
HAVE PRIVILEGES IN THAT
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT FOR EXAMPLE
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
PHYSICIANS WHO ARE ON CALL THE
CARDIOLOGISTS FOR EXAMPLE?
WE WOULD NOT WANT TO SEE A
CARDIOLOGISTS SUPERVISING A PA
IN THE MERCY DEPARTMENT.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS A METHOD FOR
IDENTIFYING WHO THE SUPERVISING
PHYSICIAN IS -- IN OUR
EXPERIENCE WHEN IT COMES TO
MALPRACTICE SUITS -- THE
ATTORNEYS WILL TRY AND CAPTURE
AS MANY POSITIONS AS POSSIBLE
WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING WHO THE
SUPERVISING POSITION IS WE THINK
THIS WILL LEAD -- TO UNNECESSARY --
IDENTIFICATION OF PHYSICIANS
PULLED INTO THAT PROCESS HI WERE
ENGAGE IN CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR SPONSORS WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING THOSE AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN LOW AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS JED
GRANT I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT BOREDOM A PA
PRACTICED EMERGENCY MEDICINE FOR
TWENTY YEARS.
OF A COMPANY BY XAVIER MARTINEZ
WHO IS A PUBLIC MEMBER OF THE
BOARD AS WELL AS SUPPORT STAFF
AND COUNCIL.
I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY
OF POSITION ASSISTANCE THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND CENTER CAL EURO FOR TAKING
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
AND FOR WORKING WITH US TO TRY
AND RESOLVE OUR CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL.
I AGREE WITH THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL REMAIN HOPEFUL THAT IF YOU
BUT SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC
PROTECTION PROBLEMS WITH THE
BILL CAN BE RESOLVED.
THE AUTHOR STRESSES THE
IMPORTANT ACCESS TO CARE THAT
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW AND WE
AGREE HOWEVER THE POPULATION
THIS BILL WILL SERVICE
VULNERABLE AND NEEDS PROTECTION.
THE PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT BOARD
HAS FOUR MAIN CONCERNS WITH SB
SIX NINETY SEVEN THE FIRST BEING
SUPERVISION.
THIS BILL ALLOWS A PA TO
PRACTICE OUTSIDE THE SPECIALTY
OR USUAL AND CUSTOMARY PRACTICE
OF THE SUPERVISING PHYSICIAN
WHICH IS IN EFFECT UNSUPERVISED
PRACTICE SIMILAR TO THE
CONCERNED.
JUST REYES BY KELLY SAID.
THE TRAINING IS GENERAL IN
NATURE WHICH ALLOWS FLEXIBILITY
IN ABILITY TO CHANGE MEDICAL
SPECIALTY HOWEVER IS NOT TO THE
DEPTH OF A RESIDENCY TRAINED
PHYSICIAN. FOR EXAMPLE AFTER THE
FOURTH YEAR OF MEDICAL SCHOOL
PHYSICIANS TAKE STEP TO THE
UNITED STATES MEDICAL LICENSURE
EXAMINATION BUT HAVE NOT YET
COMPLETED RESIDENCY TRAINING AND
HAVE VERY SIMILAR -- LEVEL OF
KNOWLEDGE IS A NEW PA GRADUATE.
RECOGNIZING THIS THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL BOARD RECENTLY ENACTED
LEGISLATION TO GRANT A
RESTRICTED LICENSE TO PHYSICIANS
WHO HAVE THIS SIMILAR LEVEL OF
KNOWLEDGE TO PA'S WHICH ALLOWS
HIM TO PRACTICE SUPERVISED UNTIL
THE COMPLETION OF RESIDENCY.
ADDITIONALLY THE MEDICAL BOARD
PASSED REGULATION IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR REQUIRING
SUPERVISING PHYSICIAN AND
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANTS PRACTICE IN
THE SAME.
SPECIALTY OR USUAL AND CUSTOMARY
PRACTICE THE PUBLIC NEEDS US
PROTECTION WHICH MAY BE REMOVED
BY THIS BILL.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL DOES NOT
ALLOW FOR TIMES WHEN THE
PHYSICAL PRESENCE OF THE
POSITION MAY BE REQUIRED BECAUSE
IT DEFINES SUPERVISION IS
SPECIFICALLY NOT REQUIRING THE
PRESENCE OF THE PHYSICIAN.
THEIR TIME SUCH AS DURING
SURGERY OR IN CASES INVOLVING
DISCIPLINE WHEN THE PHYSICAL
PRESENCE OF THE POSITION MAY BE
REQUIRED.
WE FEEL THAT THE PUBLIC NEEDS
THIS PROTECTION WHICH MAY BE
REMOVED BY THE BILL.
NUMBER TWO THE BILL REMOVES --
PHYSICIAN SYSTEM BOARDS OF FORTY
TO MAKE REGULATIONS MEDICINE IS
CONSTANTLY CHANGING OUR HAS ARE
THE LAWS RELATING TO THE
REGULATION OF MEDICAL PRACTICE.
THE P. BOARD NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO
CRAFT REGULATIONS TO ALLOW FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF LAWS
PASSED BY THE LEGISLATURE AS
WELL AS TO ALLOW FOR CHANGES IN
THE CLINICAL PRACTICE
ENVIRONMENT.
NOTABLY WE HAVE SEVERAL
REGULATIONS IN THE PROCESS OF
BEING APPROVED INCLUDING BILL
INTRODUCED BY CHAIRMAN LOW LAST
YEAR WHICH WE WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO IMPLEMENT UNDER THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL.
WHICH FREEZES PA BE REGULATORY
AUTHORITY ON JUNE SEVENTH.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN I'M NOT
AWARE OF ANY OTHER BOARD OF YOUR
OWN APARTMENT CONSUMER AFFAIRS
AND HAS SUCH STRICT CONEY AND
RESTRICTIONS NOR WHY SUCH
RESTRICTIONS WOULD BE NEEDED.
NUMBER THREE I NECESSARY CHANGES
COMING UP FOR US PLEASE.
SO THERE ARE SOME CHANGES TO
PRESCRIBING LAWS THAT WE HAVE
CONCERNS WITH AS WELL AS
ALLOWING UNLICENSED PERSONS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE SCOPE AND
DEFINITION OF DUTIES OF THE PA.
WE DO.
APPRECIATE THE COOPERATION WE'VE
HAD FROM THE AUTHOR AND SPA --
SPONSORS AND WE ANTICIPATE
WORKING WITH THEM IN THE FUTURE.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK BRIEFLY IN OPPOSITION MR
MEMBERS TO MATT AND MARK FROM
ALSO REPRESENTS THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF PLASTIC SURGEONS AS
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
RHEUMATOLOGY ALLIANCE YOU ALSO
HAVE AN OPPOSE LISTEN IN A
POSITION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHICH IS
BEACON OPPOSITION.
SEEN NONE NOW ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM CONSUMERS AT THIS
TIME.
HE NO QUESTIONS [inaudible]
DOCTOR RAMYA.
THANK YOU AND I I'LL START BY
THANKING YOU SENATOR COMING AT
ALL I KNOW YOUR PASSION AND
COMMITMENT.
TO INCREASING ACCESS IN PLACES
LIKE THE VALLEY IN THE CENTRAL
COAST AND THIS BILL GOES A LONG
WAY TOWARDS TRYING TO ADDRESS IT.
I WAS HOPING THAT YOU COULD
SPEAK TO THE OPPOSITION FROM THE
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS.
PARTICULARLY REGARDING
SUPERVISION.
AND HOW WE ENSURE THAT.
MANY PHYSICIANS DON'T GET
INCLUDED INTO SUPERVISING IF
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE WERE.
DOING ON OUR SHIPS HOW DO WE
ALLOW PHYSICIANS' ASSISTANCE TO
RECOGNIZE THE BENEFITS THAT
NURSE PRACTITIONERS HAVE.
WHILE STILL INSURING THAT
SUPERVISION IS THERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- SOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA -- THIS --
PROCESS HAS ENCOURAGED.
THERE'S A STAKEHOLDERS GROUPS
THAT HAVE BEEN MEETING -- THESE
ISSUES ON AT THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED BY THE EMERGENCY ROOM
WORKING ON IN TERMS OF LANGUAGE
WE JUST COULDN'T GET THE
LANGUAGE.
BACK FROM LEDGE COUNCIL IN ORDER
TO MEET THE DEADLINE OF OF THIS
PARTICULAR COMMITTEE BUT WERE
VERY SENSITIVE TO IT WE'VE
COMMITTED OURSELVES TO WORK ON
THE LANGUAGE MAKE SURE -- THAT
NUMBER ONE THAT WERE IDENTIFYING
THE SUPERVISOR WE THINK THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT AND NUMBER TWO
THAT THAT.
THAT THEY THAT THE SUPERVISOR
HAVE THIS THE SAME MEDICAL
TRAINING AT THAT THE PA HAS --
WEEK WE COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND I
THINK IN TERMS OF THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED I WANT TO
SAY THAT WE'RE WORKING ON ALMOST
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF THE SIX TO FOUR
RATIO.
THAT.
INITIALLY THE BILL -- HAD A HAD
THE SIX PA'S.
TO TWO A DOCTOR THAT SUPERVISING
AND DOCTOR PAN HAD SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT AND WAS REALLY
LOOKING FOR SOME KIND OF
AUTHORITY TO SAY THAT IT'S IT'S
ADEQUATE SUPERVISION TO HAVE SIX
UNDER SO WE INDIFFERENCE TO
DOCTOR PAN.
MADE IT THE ORIGINAL FOR AND SO
THAT THAT WE'RE NOT
CONTEMPLATING.
BUT OTHERWISE -- ALMOST EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THE OF THE ISSUES
ARE ARE BEING DISCUSSED AND
WE'RE WORKING ON LANGUAGE AS WE
SPEAK.
THEN THREE YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
FIVE MAY WITH THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT ON WILLING TO MOVE THE
BILL ONE APPROPRIATE.
WILD.
WAITING TO SEE THE END RESULTS
OF THE AMENDMENTS AND RESERVING
MY RIGHT TO VOTE FOR IT ON THE
FLOOR UNDERSTOOD LOOK FORWARD.
TO WORKING WITH YOUR OFFICE TO
GETTING THOSE AMENDMENTS CORRECT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR INTO
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AT THIS
TIME.
AND JUST A FOR A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION THAT IT BECAUSE IT-WAS BROUGHT UP OF A MEN'S THAT
HAVE BEEN REFLECTED ANALYSIS WE
BELIEVE ADDRESSES THE P. B. P.
BOARDS CONCERNS WITH RESPECT TO
REGULATIONS AND SUPERVISION --
IS THAT IS THAT YOUR SIMILAR
UNDERSTAND THAT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING YES.
OKAY GREAT.
SO THERE'S BEEN A MOTION SECOND
SO SENATOR I DO WISH CLOSE.
I'M AT THANK VERY VERY MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENTED
SPELLING FOR THE QUESTIONS I'M
OBVIOUSLY EXTREMELY CONCERNED
WITH THE LACK OF HEALTH CARE
AXIS IN MANY COMMUNITIES.
PEOPLE ARE FORCED TO DRIVE MORE
THAN AN HOUR JUST TO BE ABLE TO
GET AN APPOINTMENT AND MANY
COMMUNITIES HAVE NO PHARMACIES
IN THEIR COMMUNITY AT ALL AND SO
WE'VE GOT TO DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO CREATE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO PUT --
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE TRAINED AND
THAT ARE CAPABLE OF WORKING IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND IN OUT INTO
THE COMMUNITY SO THAT WE CAN
MAKE HEALTH CARE REAL. FOR MANY
OF OUR FAMILIES THAT JUST DON'T
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY GET IN SEE A
DOCTOR SO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR APPLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER THAT
YOU VERY MUCH FOR ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE MINUTES AND CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH OPPOSITION AS THIS
CONTINUES MOVE FORWARD SO
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION A SECOND
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
SB SIX NINETY SEVEN MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW.
THE FIBRO.
I ARAMBULA REMAIN AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAN CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GLORIA GRAYSON.
HOLDEN IRWIN MCCARTY MEDINA
MULLIN OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
TING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE BILL HAS SIX WHICH WILL BE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW MOVE ON THEN TO OUR NEXT
AUTHOR.
AND WILL BEGIN IN ORDER -- FILE
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
SEVEN CENTER GLAZER [inaudible]
BUT SENATE BECAUSE YOU'RE
WELCOME [inaudible]
MORNING EVERYBODY.
THIS IS THE SB SIX A SIX THAT IS
THAT CORRECT.
OKAY.
SB.
SIX ZERO SIX HIGHLIGHT A NUMBER
SEVEN RIGHT THANK YOU -- SB SIX
A SIX MAKES VARIOUS CHANGES TO
THE OPERATIONS OF THE CEMETERY
AND FUNERAL BUREAU AND EXTENDS
THE OPERATIONS OF THE BOARD OF
BARBER IN COSMETOLOGY.
THE BILL REMOVES THE PERIOD OF
TIME FOR RETAKING THE EMBALMERS
EXAMINATION.
AND REQUIRES THE BUREAU TO BE
REVIEWED BY THE APPROPRIATE
POLICY COMMITTEE OF THE
LEGISLATURE AGAIN AND IN FOUR
YEARS.
THE BILL EXTENDS THE OPERATIONS
OF THE BOARD OF BARBER IN
COSMETOLOGY UNTIL JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO ALLOW FOR A
PROPER REVIEW WITH THE BOARD
BARBER IN COSMETOLOGY ACT.
AND REGULATION OF THE
BEAUTIFICATION SERVICE INDUSTRY.
EXCEPT THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SURE MEMBERS JERRY DOESN'T ON
BEHALF OF THE CEMETERY MORTUARY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE AND AS
THE ANALYSIS TALK ABOUT ISSUES
RAISED IN THE SUNSET REVIEW IF
THE SENATOR CONSIDER THOSE
ISSUES WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HIM. TO ADDRESS
THEM SATISFACTORY PROTECT
CONSUMERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
CNN ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS COME
THROUGH COULD BE MEMBERS SEEN ON
SENATOR GLAZER DO WISH TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND YOUR
AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US ON THE SUNSET REVIEW ASKED
FOR SEXUALLY ASTRONAUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
TRIBULATION AS SIMILARLY AS IT
WITH RESPECT TO THIS AND TO THE
FUTURE SUNSET.
BILLS AS WELL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING VERY
COLLABORATIVELY WITH US AND SO --
COMMITTEE SIXTY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SB SIX ZERO SIX MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
THOUGH I BROKE.
MY REGULAR REVIEW AYE BLOOM.
THEN MY CHIN CHEN AYE CHIU
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN FONG FONG AYE
GIPSON GLORIA GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
OBERNOLTE TING.
THE BILL HAS SIX WHAT WILL BE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS.
THEN FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
WHICH IS SB.
SIX ZERO EIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
SB SIX AWAIT EXTENDS THE SUNSET
DATE. FOR CALIFORNIA'S ARCHITECT
BOARD AND THE LANDSCAPE
ARCHITECT TECHNICAL COMMITTEE
UNTIL JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND ADDRESSES
ISSUES RAISED IN THE COMMITTEES
BACKGROUND PAPER.
THE REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
ARCHITECTS BOARD TO PAMI GATE
REGULATIONS ESTABLISHING
QUALIFICATIONS FOR CONTINUING
EDUCATION COURSE WORK.
AND PROVIDERS BY JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THE MEASURE
ALSO AUTHORIZES THE BOARD'S
EXECUTIVE OFFICER TO DELEGATE
THE ABILITY TO HOLD AN INFORMAL
CONFERENCE WITH THE PERSON WHO
RECEIVED A CITATION.
ALLOWS THAT PERSON TO APPEAL THE
OUTCOME OF THIS CONFERENCE.
A SIX AWAIT ADDITIONALLY
REQUIRES LICENSE APPLICANTS TO
SUBMIT FINGERPRINTS FOR A
BACKGROUND CHECK.
THE LANDSCAPE ARCHITECT
TECHNICAL COMMITTEE THE BILL
UPDATES THE WRITTEN CONTRACT
REQUIREMENTS.
AND ALSO REQUIRES LICENSE
APPICANTS TO SUBMIT
FINGERPRINTS FOR A BACKGROUND
CHECK.
THE BILL MEASURES OF THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER WILL BE ABLE
TO PERFORM THE SAME
ADMINISTRATIVE AND ENFORCEMENT
DUTIES. FOR THE COMMITTEE AS THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER PERFORMS FOR
THE BOARD THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
I'M AWARE OF AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR NINE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MORE IS IN A GUY WITH A
CALIFORNIA ARCHITECTS FOR YOUR
SUPPORT I THINK THE AUTHOR IS
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHURNED OUT OF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MARC CHRISTIAN
WITH THE AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF
ARCHITECTS CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EDITION OF
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS JASON ACTED
WITH THAT'LL STAND OVER ROPES
AND SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL THE AMERICAN
SOCIETY OF LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS
ALSO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT CNN
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SENATOR
GLAZERS JEWISH TO CLOSE THANK
YOU AGAIN MISTER CHAIR AND YOUR
STAFF FOR YOUR WORK WITH OURS ON
THE SUNSET REVIEW AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THIS
MOTION BY DOCTOR RAMBLIN A
SECOND BY MISTER FONG RESEARCHER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB SIX ZERO EIGHT MOTIONS
DISASTER PREPARATIONS LOW LOW
AYE BRO.
THE MOBILE I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN FONG.
BOB KNIGHT GIPSON GLORIA GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN MCCARTY MEDINA
MULLIN OBERNOLTE TING. SIX
TOTALLY THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND A GLAZER THEN ON
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN SB. SIX
TEN SIX I'M SORRY SB. SIX ZERO
NINE SIX SIX OH NINE THANK YOU.
A SIX A NINE IS THE SENSE THAT
BILL FOR THE BUREAU OF SECURITY
AND INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES.
I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN YOUR
ANALYSIS ON PAGE.
ELEVEN APPRECIATE AGAIN YOUR
GOOD WORK MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT
THAT OF YOUR STAFF ON THIS
MEASURE. SIX A NINE EXTENDS THE
BUREAU SUNSET UNTIL JANUARY
FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR THE BILL
MERGES THE PRIVATE INVESTIGATOR
FIND AND THE PRIVATE SECURITY TO
CREATE ADMINISTRATIVE
EFFICIENCIES. SIX OH NINE ALIGNS
THE BUREAU STATUTES WITH THE
PENAL CODE RESTRICTING THE FEAR
OF THE ISSUE AND FIREARM PERMITS
INDIVIDUALS FOR AT LEAST TWENTY
ONE YEARS OF AGE.
THE BILL ALSO PLACES
RESPONSIBILITY FOR COMPLETING
VARIOUS TRAININGS ON GUARD
REGISTRANTS INSTEAD OF THEIR
EMPLOYERS.
IN ORDER TO BETTER ENSURE THE
SECURITY GUARDS ARE PROPERLY
TRAINED AND WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
LYNN AND REYES BUREAU CHIEF FOR
THE BUREAU OF SECURITY
INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES HERE TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE.
I NEED TO KNOW.
JERRY DOES BEEN A CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LICENSED
INVESTIGATORS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AND A NOTE ON TO POLICY
ISSUES THAT THE SENATOR
DISCUSSED -- WE'VE KNOWN THAT
THE ADJUSTMENT WAS IN THE WORKS
BECAUSE THE LAST YEAR THE FEES
WERE RAISED ON THE OTHER
PROFESSIONS IN THE SAME BUREAU
AND THAT OUR TIME THAT THAT
WOULD BE NOW.
WE SEEN THE FEES THAT ARE
INCREASES THAT ARE BEING ADDED
IN THE BILL TODAY THROUGH THE
COMMITTEE HEARING OVER NEUTRAL
ON THOSE WE KNOW THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE IT HAVEN'T RACE
SINCE THE NINETIES.
AND ALSO THE MERGER OF THE FUND
IN ORDER TO ACCOMPLISH
DEFICIENCIES THAT SENATOR GLAZER
MENTIONED.
IT'S WERE.
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
CNN ANY MEMBERS OF PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
MEMBERS.
SEE NINE SENATOR GLAZERS JEWISH
TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND TO BE SECURE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB SIX ZERO NINE IS MUCH AS THE
PAST AS AMENDED HER PREPARATIONS
Là M<c.cyan> ÁI BRO.</c>
BRO I ARAMBULA RUBIO AYE BLOOM.
WHEN I CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN?
WHEN I FONG [inaudible]
FUN UPLOADING.
GIPSON GLORIA GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
OBERNOLTE TANK.
THE BILL HAS SIX AUTUMN WE'VE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS.
THEN ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN
SB.
SIX TEN THANK YOU MISTER SHARE
SB SIX TEN IS A SUNSET BILL FOR
THE CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE
BOARD.
THE BILL EXTENDS THE SENSOR DATA
THE BOARD TILL JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR IN ADDITION
TO TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING
CHANGES THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
BOARD TO CONDUCT A STUDY OF THE
CURRENT CONTRACTORS BOND. TO
EVALUATE IF THE AMOUNT IS
SUFFICIENT AND REPORT BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE BY JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THIS BILL
REQUIRES INSTEAD OF AUTHORIZES
THE BOARD TO CHARGE A FEE FOR
VERIFYING THE ELECTRICIANS
CERTIFICATION REQUIREMENT
SPECIFIED IN THE LABOR CODE.
THIS BILL CLARIFIES THAT PERSONS
WITH UNSATISFIED JUDGMENTS ARE
NOT ABLE TO OBTAIN LICENSURE
WITHOUT FOR SATISFYING THAT
JUDGMENT.
I HAVE WITH ME MICHAEL.
A GEM NETSKY FROM THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
ANSWERING TECHNICAL QUESTIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ITEM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY CAN I ASK YOU FOR THE
CONTRACTORS BOARD IN SUPPORT AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- FOR TO
THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
RICHARD MARX AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF THE
AMERICAN FAR SPRINKLER
ASSOCIATION THE INDEPENDENT
ROOFING CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE PLUMBING HEATING COOLING
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIA THE
WESTERN ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION AND FOR KIM STONE
STONE ADVOCACY A. B. C. OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA ALL STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF HAVE A
QUESTION IS BEACON SUPPORT
SEEING NONE ANY OPPOSITION.
SEE NO OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COULD BE
MEMBERS.
SEEN KNOWN QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS SENATOR GLAZER DO
WAS TO CLOSE AT RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR NINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THERE'S BEEN MOTION BY DOCTOR
ARAMBULA AND A SECOND BY MISTER
CHAN CRITICS SAY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SB SIX TEN MOTIONS YOU PASTOR
PREPARATIONS LOW.
RIGHT WELL I PRO PROVIDE
ARAMBULA.
I BLOOM.
MY CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN
AYE EGGMAN AYE FONG FONG AYE
GIPSON GLORIA GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
OBERNOLTE TING.
THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES IN WITH
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS.
THEN FINALLY FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN SB.
SEVEN EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT SB SEVENTY
SIX IS THE SENATE BUSINESS
PROFESSION AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE BILL.
IT OFFERS VARIOUS TECHNICAL
MINOR NON CONTROVERSIAL CHANGES
THE BIZ PROFESSIONS CODE.
RELATING REGULATORY BOARDS AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS.
SO I UNDERSTAND IT COMMITTEE
STAFF IN THE SENATE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS HAVE WORKED WITH THE
BOARD STAFF TO DISCUSS THE
CHANGES TO THE LAW THAT ARE
CURRENTLY BEING PROPOSED.
WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NIGHT.
FANTASTIC THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT.
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE BORDER
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES IN SUPPORT.
SURE HE SPURNS BOARD OF
PSYCHOLOGY IN SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT SEEING NONE ANY
OPPOSITION FROM ANYONE.
MANY MEN IN THE PUBLIC AND
MEMBERS OF TELEVISION IF YOU CAN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COULD YOU MEMBERS
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND TWENTY SIX THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
SB SEVEN EIGHTY SIX MOTIONS TO
PAST APPROPRIATIONS LOW HI THE
I. BRO.
RIGHT ARAMBULA REMAIN AYE BLOOM.
HI JOHN CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG FONG AYE GIPSON
GLORIA GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN OBERNOLTE
TING.
AND THAT BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES.
IT'S CHAIRMAN IF I MAY AS A YES
COURTESY -- THIS KIND OF
COMPLETE THE PROCESS THAT WE
BEGAN TOGETHER IN THE IN THE
WINTER REALLY ON OUR SUNSET
REVIEWS AND I WANTED TO SAY
THANK YOU -- AND YOUR STAFF FOR
ALL THAT WORK THAT WE DID
TOGETHER THROUGH THOSE HEARING
PROCESS INTO THE BILLS THAT WE
HEARD TODAY AND AND IN MY
COMMITTEE EARLIER IN THE WEEK SO
GET THAT MY THANKS TO YOU.
LIKEWISE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE CLUB OF NATURE.
MEMBERS WORK THEN JUST WAITING
FOR AN ADDITIONAL TWO AUTHORS
THAT WE HAVE LEFT THAT'S FILE
ITEM NO THREE SB TO SEND FIVE BY
DOCTOR PAN.
AND FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
WHICH IS SB SIX SEVEN NINE BY
SENATOR BATES
[inaudible]
OKAY
.
MEMBERS WILL THEN MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE SB TO
SEND A FIVE BY DOCTOR PENS.
WELCOME -- THANK YOU.
MY WITNESSES COME [inaudible]
CHECK AGAIN.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS -- TODAY A BRING YOU SB
TWO SEVENTY FIVE THE BILL
SPONSORED BY THE BOARD OF
PSYCHOLOGY WHICH ADD SEXUAL
BEHAVIOR WHICH INCLUDES AN
APPROPRIATE ACTIONS IN
COMMUNICATIONS OF A SEXUAL
NATURE.
THEIR PRECURSOR TO OURS HARMFUL.
AS SEXUAL CONTACT WITH A CLIENT
OR FORMER CLIENT TO THE LIST OF
VIOLATIONS THAT WOULD REQUIRE IN
MINISTRY.
LARGE LAW JUDGES PROPOSED
DECISION TO INCLUDE AN ORDER
REVOCATION OF LICENSE.
CURRENT LAW THE FIND SEXUAL
CONTACT IS MEETING QUOTE SEXUAL
INTERCOURSE OR THE TOUCHING OF
AN INTIMATE PART OF THE PATIENT
FOR THE PURPOSE OF SEXUAL
AROUSAL GRATIFICATION -- ABUSE
UNQUOTE.
ADDITIONALLY CURRENT LAW DEFINES
AN INTIMATE PART AS QUOTE THE
SEXUAL ORGAN ****.
GROWING OR PRODUCTS OF ANY
PERSON AND THE BREAST OF A
FEMALE UNQUOTE.
THEREFORE YOU COULD ACTUALLY
LICKED THE NIPPLE OF THE MALE
PATIENT AND THAT WOULD NOT MEET
THIS DEFINITION.
WHICH IS CLEARLY OUTDATED.
THIS IS FAR TOO NARROW THE
DEFINITION HAS CAN AND HAS
CREATED SITUATIONS WHERE THE
BOARD HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO
REVOKE THE LICENSES OF
PSYCHOLOGISTS.
WHO HAVE HAD INAPPROPRIATE
CONTACT WITH THE PATIENT?
IN THE PAST FIVE YEARS ALL BUT
ONE ALL BUT ONE OF THE CASES
THAT WENT BEFORE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE WERE
UNABLE TO RESULT IN A REVOCATION.
DUE TO THIS OUTDATED NARROW
DEFINITION.
SO SB TWO SEVENTY FIVE WITH THE
FIND SEXUAL BEHAVIOR AS QUOTE
INAPPROPRIATE CONTACT THE
COMMUNICATION OF A SEXUAL NATURE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF SEXUAL
AROUSAL GRATIFICATION
EXPLOITATION FOR ABUSE.
SEXUAL BEHAVIOR DOES NOT INCLUDE
THE PROVISION OF APPROPRIATE
THERAPEUTIC INTERVENTIONS
RELATED TO SEXUAL ISSUES ON
QUOTE.
THE BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY WANTS TO
ENSURE THAT SEXUAL BEHAVIOR WITH
A CLIENT EVEN IF IT HAS NOT
ACTUALLY RESULTED IN ACTUAL
INTERCOURSE TO SEXUAL CONTACT
CONTACT.
IS AN EGREGIOUS ETHICAL
VIOLATION THAT MERITS THE
HIGHEST LEVEL DISCIPLINE.
AND THE REVOCATION OF A LICENSE.
THE BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY HAS
EXPERIENCED CASES INVOLVING
INAPPROPRIATE SEXUAL CONTACT
THAT THAT THAT DID NOT MEET THE
CURRENT DEFINITION OF SEXUAL
CONTACT.
AND THEREFORE DID NOT REQUIRED
THE ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE TO
RECOMMEND WROTE REVOKING THE
LICENSE.
SO SOME EXAMPLES OF SEXUAL
BEHAVIORS THAT THE BOARD HAS
SEEN AND DISCIPLINARY CASES THAT
DID NOT REACH THE LEVEL OF
SEXUAL CONTACT INCLUDE.
KISSING A CLIENT.
TOUCHING EXPOSING ONESELF AND
APPROPRIATELY.
SO WHICH MEANS THAT A
PSYCHOLOGIST COULD ACTUALLY ****
AND FROM THEIR PATIENT.
AND THE BOARD WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO REVOKE THE LICENSE.
SENDING FLIRTATIOUS SEXUALLY
SUGGESTIVE EXPLICIT TAX.
MESSAGES OR EMAILS TO CLIENTS.
SETTING THE CLIENTS PHOTOS
INCLUDE NUDITY THE GENITALIA
GENERAL'S SEXUALLY SUGGESTIVE
POSES.
AND WE KNOW TECHNOLOGISTS CHANGE
WE NEED THE ALSO UPDATE THE CODE
ADDRESS SEXTING.
OUR BY ROMANTIC OR SEXUAL GIFTS
FOR A CLIENT SO I GUESS YOU CAN
SEND SOMEONE SEX TOY THAT WOULD
NOT VIOLATE THE COAT.
SB TWO SEVENTY FIVE WOULD MAKE
THIS CLEAR UNDER THE LAW THAT
THESE SEXUAL CAUGHT BEHAVIORS
WITH A CLIENT OUR SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT AND I HOPE EVERYONE
HERE CAN AGREE.
THAT SHOULD BE SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
SEXUAL BEHAVIOR IN THIS I CAUGHT
PSYCHOTHERAPIST CLIENT
RELATIONSHIP BY A LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL IS AN ETHICAL
VIOLATION.
AS IT VIOLATES A DUTY OF CARE
INHERENT IN A THERAPEUTIC
RELATIONSHIP.
AND WHEN WE THINK ABOUT WHEN YOU
GO SEEK HELP FROM A FROM A
PSYCHOLOGIST.
YOU KNOW YOU YOU GO IN THERE.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A LEVEL OF
TRUST BUT ALSO LEVEL
VULNERABILITY BECAUSE IN PART OF
THE THEIR PEAK RELATIONSHIP YOU --
EXPECTED TO I EXPECTED TO I MEAN
IN ORDER TO GET THE TREATMENT
YOU NEED.
SHARE SOME OF YOUR MOST INTIMATE
NO ANXIETIES FEARS AND COLLUDING
ONES THAT ARE SEXUAL YOU ARE IN
A VULNERABLE POSITION.
THE PSYCHOTHERAPIST CLIENT
RELATIONSHIP IS UNIQUE TO YOUR
STEERING SOME THE MOST INTIMATE
PARTS OF YOUR PSYCHE.
YOU TALK TO YOUR THERAPIST ABOUT
THINGS YOU DON'T TALK TO ANYONE
ELSE.
EVEN A SPOUSE OR SIGNIFICANT
OTHER -- FAMILY MEMBER.
THAT CREATES A POWER DYNAMIC
THAT SHOULD NOT BE EXPLOITED.
NOW THE WELL THE BOARD HAS
DISCUSSED THIS ISSUE WITH THE
OFFICE OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
TO ADDRESS PROSECUTE YOUR
PROSECUTORIAL ROLE.
THE BOARD BELIEVES THAT
INAPPROPRIATE SEXUAL BEHAVIOR
THE CLIENT BEYOND SEXUAL CONTACT
IS SEXUAL MISCONDUCT AND SHOULD
BE PROSECUTED JUDICATA SUCH.
WE MUST GIVE THE ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISMS IN PLACE THE POWER TO
STOP SEXUAL PREDATORS AND
PREVENT THEM FROM CONTINUING TO
PRACTICE BY BEING ABLE TO REVOKE
THE LICENSE.
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME THE BOARD
OF PSYCHOLOGY PRESIDENT.
STEPHEN PHILLIPS WHO'S GOING TO
SPEAK DIRECTLY TO THE BOARD
EXPERIENCE AND THE NEED FOR SB.
TWO SEVENTY FIVE AND THEN I ALSO
HAVE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR ANSON AT
SOREK THE ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AS WELL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL
TO ENSURE THAT WE DEAL WITH.
WITH THIS VERY SERIOUS ISSUE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
A FIGHT UP TO THREE MINUTES FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
A GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN LOW --
VICE CHAIRMAN BRO AND HIS TEAM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR STEPHEN
PHILLIPS AND I COME TO YOU TODAY
AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD OF
PSYCHOLOGY AND A LICENSED
PSYCHOLOGIST FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS.
THE BOARD IS PLEASED TO BE THE
SPONSOR BEST BE TWO SEVENTY FIVE
AND SINCERELY THANKS CENTER PAN
FOR ALL THREE IN THIS BILL.
IN THIS AGE OF OUR SENSITIVITY
TO SEXUAL EXPLOITATION BY PEOPLE
IN A POSITION OF POWER.
A REMEDY TO THE PROBLEMS OF
WE'RE LOOKING AT IS LONG OVERDUE.
IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT --
SOME MEMBERS HAVE EXPRESSED
CONCERN THAT THIS IS AN
UNNECESSARY PROVISION.
BUT WITHOUT THE PROVISION THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WE ARE LEFT
IN A POSITION WHERE WE CAN ONLY
ALLEGE THAT PEOPLE ENGAGE AND
UNPROFESSIONAL CONDUCT.
WHICH DOES NOT ALLOW US IN
VIRTUALLY ANY CASE TO GET
REVOCATION.
SO WE'RE LEAVING SEXUAL
PREDATORS.
IN A POSITION WHERE THEY STILL
HAVE A LICENSE TO PRACTICE
PSYCHOLOGY AND SEE PATIENTS.
VIOLATING THE TRUST OF A PATIENT
IN THIS WAY IS PERHAPS THE MOST
EGREGIOUS VIOLATION OF THE DUTY
AND TRUSTED HIS REPOSE AND A
PSYCHOLOGIST.
I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE
OF A CASE IN WHICH THERE WAS
PROBATION GIVEN RATHER THAN
REVOCATION.
THE PSYCHOLOGIST BEGAN SEEING A
CLIENT AND FOR ANXIETY AND IN
THE FIRST SESSION AS THE CLIENT
IF SHE'S HAVING SEX AND HOW
OFTEN.
SCOTT PSYCHOLOGIST AND MADE
SUBJECTIVE STATEMENTS THE CLIENT
TOLD HER HOW BEAUTIFUL SHE WAS
AND HOW ATTRACTIVE SHE WAS AND
HOW LUCKY HER BOYFRIEND WAS.
THE PSYCHOLOGIST TOLD THE CLIENT
ABOUT ANOTHER CLIENT WHO SPREAD
THEIR LEGS TO SHOW THEY HAVE NO
PANTIES.
AND SAID THAT WHEN HE WAS
INTIMATE WITH HIS WIFE HE
THOUGHT ABOUT.
THEN THE RELATIONSHIP CHANGED
THEY STARTED USING FAMILIAR
NAMES AND HE WOULD PUT HIS HAND
ARE BACK.
THEY NO LONGER DISCUSS THERAPY
AND BEGAN HOLDING HANDS KISSING
ON THE FACE THE DEMIGOD SITTING
NEXT TO EACH OTHER DURING
SESSIONS.
AND AT ONE POINT THE PATIENT'S
STRADDLED THE THERAPIST ON THE
COUCH.
THERE WAS UNDRESSING INVOLVED.
THE PSYCHOLOGIST REPEATEDLY
ASKED FOR PHOTOGRAPHS OF THE
PATIENT WITH NUDITY.
THE PSYCHOLOGIST THREATEN THE
CLIENT IF SHE SPOKE ABOUT
BEHAVIOR.
AND SHE SUBSEQUENTLY BECAME
SUICIDAL.
THE RESULT OF OUR PROCEEDINGS
AGAINST HIM BECAUSE WE COULD NOT
SEEK REVOCATION UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
THE PSYCHOLOGIST RECEIVED
PROBATION AND STILL HAVE THE
ABILITY TO CONTINUE TO SEE
PATIENTS.
THIS TYPE OF OUTRAGEOUS BEHAVIOR
PARTICULARLY IN THE DIGITAL AGE.
IS ONE THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED WE HAVE AN OUTDATED
DEFINITION THAT NEEDS A MUCH
BROADER SENSE SO THAT WE CAN
STOP SEXUAL PREDATORS FROM USING
THEIR CYCLE PSYCHOLOGIST LICENSE.
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF VULNERABLE
PEOPLE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
IN INSTALLATION IF YOU WISH TO
DO SO [inaudible]
PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS GONNA PUT UP
SINGLE I'M A LICENSED PHYSICIAN
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEN THEN ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM KEY MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
DOCTOR EGGMAN.
I THINK YOU THINK A DOCTOR PAN
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- AND
CERTAINLY THE THINGS THAT YOU
DESCRIBED -- ARE NOT OKAY AND
UNDER IN NO CONDITION THIS.
THE THINGS YOU DESCRIBED ALRIGHT
BUT I GUESS I'M WONDERING THAT
THE BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY -- CAN'T
REVOKE SOMEBODY'S LICENSE BUT
THE BNP CODE CLEARLY COVERS
SEXUAL CONTACT THAT ANYBODY'S
LICENSE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
MUST FOLLOW -- SO THE SECTIONS
SAID. SEVEN TWENTY SIX AND SEVEN
TWENTY NINE SEEM TO COVER ALL
THE THINGS THAT YOU'RE
DISCUSSING -- THAT AGAIN THE
BORDER PSYCHOLOGY MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO REMOVE SOMEBODY'S LYSONS
BY THE BNP CODE WHICH GOVERNS --
SOMEBODY HAVING A VALID LICENSE
THOSE THOSE POLICIES ALREADY IN
PLACE TO PROVIDE THE KIND OF
PROTECTION THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT BECAUSE I MEAN IF YOU DO
IF WE JUST GOING TO PSYCHOLOGIST
I MEAN IS A LOT OF PEOPLE DO
THERAPY LCSW -- AND HAVE TV'S
POSITION PSYCHIATRISTS IF YOU
WILL -- SO I SO I GUESS IS MY
QUESTION IS IF THESE ARE ALREADY
COVERED THE BNP CODE THAT THAT
GO FOR ALL THE HELPING
PROFESSIONS WHY DO WE NEED THIS
SPECIAL.
ONE JUST FOR PSYCHOLOGIST.
NO I THINK THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION AND AND I GUESS FIRST
OF ALL I WOULD JUST SAY IS IS
THAT -- IN RELATION -- TO IS
THAT THE BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY AND
I DON'T ACTUALLY I HAVEN'T
REALLY ANSWER YOUR QUESTION IT
IS RESULTS THEIR BILL SO.
AND AS YOU HEARD IN THE
TESTIMONY HAD CHALLENGES
ACTUALLY -- PROSECUTING BECAUSE
THE THE SENSHI TO TWENTY GENERAL
OFF THE OJ WITH WILL NOT REVOKE
THE LICENSE BUT PERHAPS AND LET
ME HAVE THAT FOR PSYCHOLOGY
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS THE CODE
SECTIONS THAT YOU REFER TO KNOW
WHY THEY CAN'T ACT.
SO -- SEVEN TWENTY SIX I'M SORRY
A THREE SPURS FOR PSYCHOLOGY --
SO DOES BMP SEVEN TWENTY SIX
ACTUALLY ENDS YOU WITH PER
UNPROFESSIONAL CONDUCT AND THE
BOARD HAS HAD A HISTORY OF USING
UNPROFESSIONAL CONDUCT FOR
SEXUAL BEHAVIORS BUT NOT BEING
ABLE TO SKATE REVOCATION FOR
THAT.
SO THE PROBLEM IS YOU CAN OF
COURSE USE UNPROFESSIONAL
CONDUCT BUT YOU'RE GONNA END UP
WITH THE PROBATION MAYBE FIVE TO
SEVEN YEARS MAYBE SOME ETHICAL
CLASSES CLASSES COURSES ABOUT
BOUNDARIES -- BUT THEN YOU'RE
AGAIN FREE AND CLEAR TO PRACTICE --
SO THERE.
IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS AND
THAT'S FOR THE NINE CASES WE'VE
SEEN OF SEXUAL BEHAVIOR THAT WE
WEREN'T ABLE TO GET REVOCATION.
FOR ALL OF THOSE END UP AN
UNPROFESSIONAL CONDUCT THEY END
UP IN PROBATION THEY END UP
RIGHT BACK OUT THERE AND ABLE TO
PRACTICE AND AGAIN WE'RE A
CONSUMER COMPLAINT DRIVEN AGENCY.
SO WE ONLY GET TO GO AFTER THE
COMPLAINTS THAT WE GET THAT
DOESN'T EVEN INCLUDE THOSE
PATIENTS THAT HAVEN'T COME
FORWARD THAT MAY HAVE ALSO BEEN
EXPLOITED BY THESE THERAPISTS.
SO.
OUR ABILITY TO TAKE THAT EXTRA
MEASURE USED TWENTY NINE SIXTY
POINT ONE AND ARE PRESS THAT ARE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
PRACTICE ACT.
THAT'S THE REVOCATION MECHANISM
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
USE FOR THIS -- NOT
UNPROFESSIONAL CONDUCT WHICH SO
FAR DOES NOT RESULT IN
REVOCATION EVEN IN THE MOST
EGREGIOUS EXAMPLES LIKE THE ONE
DR PHILIP TO AND SEVEN TWENTY
NINE YOU SAY DOES NOT A WOULD
NOT BE SUFFICIENT AS WELL SEVEN
TWENTY NINE IS IT SUFFICIENT
BECAUSE IT USES SEXUAL CONTACT.
AND THAT CONTACT UP AND INTO
MEANT.
IT'S SEXUAL INTERCOURSE OR
CONTACT SODOMY ORAL COPULATION
SEXUAL CONTACT WITH THE PATIENT
OR CLIENT.
THAT IS YOU UP WITH TOUCHING OF
AN INTIMATE PART IN THE PENAL
CODE AND OF COURSE THAT DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE BREAST OF A MAN OR
TOUCHING OF ANY OTHER PARTS
OTHER THAN THE **** GROWING AND
THE BOX.
SO THEY'RE VERY NARROW FOR THAT
PURPOSES.
INTERMENT PART FOR THE PURPOSE
OF SEXUAL AROUSAL GRATIFICATION
OR ABUSE.
IF I COULD RESPOND JUST BRIEFLY --
WE HAVE SITUATIONS NOW WHERE
PEOPLE ARE USING THINGS LIKE
DIGITAL MEDIA WHERE THEY HAVE NO
PHYSICAL CONTACT WITH A CONTACT.
WITH THEIR COMPLETELY
PSYCHOLOGISTS ARE COMPLETELY
SEXUAL ISING.
THE RELATIONSHIP WITH THE CLIENT --
THEY COULD ENGAGE IN PHONE SEX
WITH THE CLIENT AND STILL NOT BE
SUBJECT TO REVOCATION WITHOUT
THE MEASURE THAT WE BROUGHT
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE.
AND CURRENTLY KISSING IS NOT
INCLUDED IN TOUCHING OF AN
INTIMATE PART SO THEY CAN
CONTINUE.
TO KISS AND MAKE OUT ESSENTIALLY --
AND THAT DOES NOT COUNT AS WELL.
SO THEN I GUESS MY THEN I GUESS
THEY QUIT IF IF THIS IS A
WIDESPREAD.
ISSUE.
WHICH I I DON'T KNOW THAT IT IS
BUT IF IT IF IT IS A WIDESPREAD
ISSUE THEN WHY IS IT JUST
PSYCHOLOGISM WHY ARE WE DOING
AND ALL THE HELPING PROFESSIONS
ALSO I GUESS WHAT I WOULD.
YEAH RESPOND TO THAT IS FIRST OF
ALL -- THE BOARD'S PSYCHOLOGY
CAME TO ME WITH THIS -- I THINK
THAT IF THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
THE COMMITTEE DESIRE TO AND FELT
THAT IT WAS APPROPRIATE FOR
OTHER BOARD STYLE BE CERTAINLY
THAN HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN ANY
PROPOSAL FOR AMENDMENTS. TO
ADDRESS THAT -- YEAH BUT I SO I
I THINK THE BOARDS ECOLOGY CAME
TO ME WITH THIS PROPOSAL BUT IF
THE REASON IF YOU'RE IF THINK
ISSUE IS IT'S TOO NARROW.
I CERTAINLY WOULD APPRECIATE THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE THE COMMITTEE
TO SAY WELL YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE
FAMILIAR WITH THE OTHER BOARDS
OUT I'VE BEEN AND I DON'T REALLY
HAVE THE STAFF TO GO AND ASK
EACH BOARD DO YOU NEED THIS --
SO YOU KNOW WE WERE NOT PROPOSED
ANY AMENDMENTS -- TO TO TO TRY
TO DRESS THOSE CONCERNS OF THAT
WAS A SIGNET THAT'S THE MAIN
CONCERN OF THE COMMITTEE --
WE'VE BEEN HAPPY TO TO TO
ENTERTAIN AND AND AND EXAMINE
THAT -- BUT THAT'S NOT GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SELL SO -- IT IT
IS A POOR TO PSYCHOLOGY BILL AND
THAT'S SO WHY IT IS THE WAY IT
IS RIGHT NOW BUT CERTAINLY WOULD
BEEN OPEN -- TO SEE IF PROPOSALS
FOR AMENDMENTS TO SAY WELL YOU
KNOW WHAT THERE'S OTHER YOU
WRITE THIS OTHER THERAPISTS AND
EIGHT OF THE CODE DOESN'T
ADDRESS THOSE AS WELL AND HAVE
SOME OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE OTHER BOARDS.
RACE BECAUSE HE NOW SAYS
CLINICALLY SAY SAID THE THE
THINGS YOU'RE DESCRIBING HER
ALREADY COVERED UNDER THE CODE
RIGHT SO THAT'S MEAN.
SO I GUESS THAT'S MY ISSUE IF IF
YOU KNOW OFFICES ALL CLEARLY
COVERED UNDER THE CODE.
THEN WHY WOULD WE JUST DO ONE
SMALL JUST THAT THOSE ARE MY
QUESTIONS THANK THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
AN ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AT THIS
TIME.
SEE NONE SENATOR PENN DO YOU
WISH TO CLOSE.
YES -- SO I WOULD I WOULD MAE
NOTE THAT AGAIN -- THE BEHAVIORS
ARE.
COVER BUT THE PENALTY -- IS
UNFORTUNATELY -- YOU'RE NOT ABLE
TO REMOVE THE LICENSE AND SO DO
YOU THINK ABOUT A THERAPIST WHO
ENGAGES IN THIS KIND BEHAVIOR WE
CAN PUT THEM ON PROBATION.
BUT THE BOARD AND WHO IS HERE
WHO IS TRIED.
AS AS BEEN UNABLE TO BE ABLE --
TO ACTUAL REVOKE THE LICENSES OF
PEOPLE THIS BEHAVIOR NOW HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE WE'VE
UNFORTUNATELY I'VE HAD TO DEAL
WITH THESE ISSUES -- AMONGST
WHETHER IT'S OUR COLLEAGUES IN
THE LEGISLATURE STAFF OTHER
PEOPLE WE SAID THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE AND THERE SHOULD BE
CONSEQUENCES FOR THAT.
THE BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY SAYS.
HIS JOB IT IS TO PROTECT PUBLIC
SAYS THERE SHOULD BE SIGNIFICANT
CONSERVE AND THERE'S
CONSEQUENCES IF IT.
BASICALLY IS AN ABUSE OF THAT.
THE PATIENT CLIENT RELATIONSHIP --
THE THE THERAPIST CLIENT
RELATIONSHIP. TO THE AGREE
DISAGREE THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
WE SHOULD HAVE THE OPTION OF
REVOKING THE LICENSE BECAUSE
OTHERWISE WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT.
THEY WILL STILL BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE CONTACT FUTURE PATIENTS
ARE I'M GOING PATIENTS WHEN
THEY'RE ON PROBATION AT THAT THE
MEDIA TAKING CLASSES ANY UNDER
SUPERVISION BUT AN INVENTION
PROVISIONAL AND AND SO IT'S THE
BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY WHO'S HERE
SAYING WE NEED THIS.
RIGHT IT'S NOT DOCTOR PAN GOING --
I THINK WE HAVE A PROBLEM HERE
IS THE BOARD'S PSYCHOLOGY SAYS
WE'VE TRIED WE'VE TRIED AND WE
CAN'T MAKE -- PROGRESS.
AND I THINK SO CERTAINLY FOR ALL
OF US WHO WORKED SO HARD TO BE
SURE WE CREATE A POSITIVE
ENVIRONMENT HERE.
WE NEED TO BE SURE THAT PEOPLE
EVEN MORE VULNERABLE PEOPLE ARE
SEEKING SAIKIA ELSE A
PSYCHOLOGICAL HELP.
ARE PROTECTED.
I WOULD YOU KNOW IT AGAIN I'VE
CERTAINLY BEEN OPEN TO IF THERE
ARE ANY AMENDMENTS OR SOMETHING
THE COMMITTEE -- PROPOSED.
YOU KNOW NONE OF OUR BILLS ARE
PERFECT WE ALWAYS SEEK TO
PERFECT OUR BILLS THROUGH THE
COMMITTEE PROCESS CERTAINLY I
WOULD WELCOME THAT OPPORTUNITY
BUT SO FAR HAVE NOT BEEN
PROPOSED -- ANY AMENDMENTS TO
TRY TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS
WHETHER IT'S NOT BROAD ENOUGH
FOR OTHER TYPES OF THINGS -- I
WOULD ALSO POINT OUT THAT THIS
BILL HAS.
GONE THROUGH THE SENATE I KNOW
YOU'RE DIFFERENT HOUSE -- BUT
THERE'S HAD BEEN NO NO VOTES
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL -- AND AND SO -- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
FOR THE SAFETY OF OUR PATIENTS
THAT'S WHAT THE PURPOSE OF THE
BOARD IS ASKING OUR HELP.
I HOPE YOU WILL STEP UP AND HELP
THEM TO GIVE THEM THE TOOLS THEY
NEED. TO GO AFTER THE PEOPLE WHO
REALLY SHOULD NOT BE CONTINUING
TO PRACTICE PSYCHOLOGY.
AND DISCOVERED THAT ARE STRICTLY
ASK FOR AN I. BUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- SENATOR
PAN -- FOR THE YOUR COMMITMENT
IT IN THIS AREA WE OF COURSE IN
ASSEMBLY BEING P. WILL NOT
TOLERATE ANY TYPE OF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT -- AND SHARE THE TYPE
OF CONCERNS THAT YOU HAVE ALSO
ARTICULATED A SIMILAR RELATED IS --
OUR DUTY AS A COMMITTEE TO LOOK
AT THE LAWS THAT WE HAVE ON THE
BOOKS ARE CURRENTLY AND WHETHER
OR NOT FOR EXAMPLE IS IT
REFLECTED IN THE COMMITTEE NOW
SAYS THAT THE CURRENTLY
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY.
ENTER AND WE'VE BEEN SEEING
GRANTING PROBATION -- AND
SUSPENDING LICENSES -- CURRENTLY
IN EXISTENCE ASSEMBLY WE'VE ALSO
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH OTHER
BOARDS AND ENTITIES UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
AND WILL SHARE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO LOOK AT A HOLISTIC APPROACH
TO SEE IF THIS IS A PERVASIVE
ISSUE.
A BUT UNFORTUNATELY AT THIS TIME
IS TOO NARROW IN SCOPE WHICH IS
WHY WE DO NOT OFFER ANY IMMENSE
AT THIS TIME SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMITMENT AND WILL JOIN
YOU.
IN THESE COLLECTIVE EFFORTS AS
WE EXPLORE EDITION OPPORTUNITIES
MOVING INTO THE FUTURE -- SO
HAVING SAID THAT -- IS THERE
MOTION.
CENTER AND WE WILL -- KEEP THIS
SET HERE IN IS THE COMMITTEE AT
THIS TIME AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR PRESERVATION THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DOCTOR PANICKING WELL NOW MOVE
ON TO OUR FINAL ITEM WHICH IS.
ON FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB
SIX SEVEN NINE BY SENATOR BATES.
SENATOR BASE THIS DOES ENJOY A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE SO PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
CENTER BATES AGAIN THAT THAT
DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES BUT
WE WELCOME TO PRESENT AND
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
I THANK YOU CHAIRMAN THOUGH AND
AND MEMBERS LIE AND UP.
I THINK IT'S STILL GOOD MORNING
SO GOOD MORNING ALL -- AND I
WANT TO START BY THANKING THE
HARD WORK THAT YOU PUT IN
CHAIRMAN LOW AND CONSULTANTS AND
OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE ARE
VERY VERY HAPPY TO TAKE AND I
THINK THAT THEY ARE VERY GOOD
ACTUALLY. TO PREVENT THE OF THE
LET'S SEE THIS BECOMING WIDER
SPREAD THROUGH MANY THE
LICENSEES WHICH WAS THE THE
CONCERNED SO.
I HAVE CEMENTED -- SB SIX
SEVENTY NINE SEEKS TO STREAMLINE
THE PROCESS FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE HELD A LICENSE FOR AT LEAST
TWO YEARS.
IN ANOTHER STATE FOR A THREE
SPECIFIC PROFESSIONS THAT'S
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST.
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS AND
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL COUNSELORS
UNDER CURRENT LAW THESE LICENSES
AND OTHER STATES MUST MEET ALL
EDUCATION AND SUPERVISED
EXPERIENCE REQUIREMENTS.
THAT A BRAND NEW APPLICANTS MUST
MEET WHEN THEY COME TO
CALIFORNIA EVEN IF THEY HAVE
BEEN LICENSED FOR MANY YEARS OR
PERHAPS DECADES IN THEIR HOME
STATE.
THE BILL HONORS THE EXPERIENCE
THAT LICENSEES HAVE HAVE IN
THEIR HOME STATE WHILE STILL
MAKING SURE.
THEY OBTAIN ADDITIONAL COURSE
WORK TO TEACH CALIFORNIA
SPECIFIC LAWS AND HELP THEM
PRACTICE OF FESTIVELY.
AND NOT CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
ENVIRONMENT THE PROPOSAL IS
CONSISTENT WITH EFFORTS THAT ARE
GOING ON AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL
TO IMPROVE LICENSE PORTABILITY
ACROSS STATES.
IN IT IS ALSO IN LINE WITH
RECENT RECOMMENDATIONS OF
CALIFORNIA'S LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION -- WITH ME TODAY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE ARE KIM MADSON AND ROSEANNE
HELMS WITH THE BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM KIM
MANSON THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR
THE BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY AND EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION AND THANKS TO
SENATOR BATES FOR AUTHORING THIS
BILL.
SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY NINE
WILL HELP MEET THE INCREASING
DEMAND FOR MENTAL HEALTH
LICENSEES TO BE MORE PORTABLE
ACROSS STATE LINES OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS THE BOARD HAS
ACTIVELY PARTICIPATED.
IN THIS DISCUSSION AT A NATIONAL
LEVEL WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORK BOARDS THE NATIONAL
BOARD OF CERTIFIED COUNSELORS.
AND THE ASSOCIATION OF MARRIAGE
AND FAMILY REGULATORY BOARDS ALL
THESE PROFESSIONAL ORGANIZATIONS
ARE WORKING ON PROPOSALS TO
INCREASE PORTABILITY. FOR
EXISTING LICENSES -- WE'RE
EXCITED TO BE THE SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL WE THINK -- EVERYONE'S
EFFORTS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF PUBLIC
WHICH IS BEACON SUPPORT.
G. V. AIRS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL COUNSELORS
WE APPRECIATE -- THE BOARD OF
THE AUTHOR I APPRECIATE THE
BOARD'S DELIVERED OF APPROACH TO
THIS -- NATIONWIDE -- OVER A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND
PROFESSIONAL COUNSELORS -- IN
CALIFORNIA.
AT THE LPC SEES ONLY -- OBTAIN
LICENSURE IN THE FIRST LICENSES
WERE ISSUED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE SO WE HAVE VERY FEW
MEMBERS THERE ARE NUMBER OF
LICENSEES THAT WOULD LIKE TO
COME. TO CALIFORNIA PAY TAXES IN
CALIFORNIA AND SERVE CALIFORNIA
CLIENTS AND SO WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
CHECK OF REGULAR THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
HEALTH WHEN A CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
TOM RENT FREE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEEN ON ANY
WITNESSES WHICH IS BEGIN
OPPOSITION SEE NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THIS BEEN IN MOTION
AND A SECOND COMMITTEE SIX THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB SIX SEVENTY NINE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH LOW AYE
BRO [inaudible]
BLOOM.
WHEN I CHAN?
CHAN I CHILL.
COMING UP.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
AGAIN I FONG FUNG I GIVE SEND
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
AYE GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MCCARTY AREN'T IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE REALTY I TING.
THE BILL HAS TWELVE VOTES I
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS THAT'S AT THE COMPLETION
OF ALL THE BILLS TO BE PRESENTED
SO WE'LL GO AND FILE ORDER -- TO
ALLOW FOR ADDITIONAL.
MISTER CHAIR IF I COULD YES --
MAKING SEVEN I JUST WANT -- TO
WE HAD CENTER NIELSEN PERCENT
EARLIER AND YOU HAD SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL BUT I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH HIM AFTER THE FACT TO MOVE
THE BILL FORD I JUST WONDER.
NOW SO PUBLICLY YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO WORK WITH HIM ON THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF BECAUSE
VICE YOUR BILL YOU BROUGHT THAT
UP -- I WAS GOING TO WIN TO THAT
ITEM CAME ABOUT BECAUSE YOU DID
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YES MEMBERS
WE'VE BEEN INITIAL CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE SENATOR NIELSEN'S
OFFICE. TO PROVIDE THE COURTESY
OF ALLOWING HIS BILL TO MOVE
FORWARD BUT I SHOULD IT NOT BE
SUFFICIENT WITH RESPECT TO SOME
OF THESE ISSUES AND RECOGNIZING
THE GENUINE INTENT OF TRYING TO
A COMPOSITION ISSUE -- WE WILL
GIVE A I'VE RECOMMENDATION A TO
SUPPORT THE BILL MOVING FORWARD --
BUT IF IT DOES GET TO THE FLOOR
AS IS THEN WE CAN RESERVE THAT
RIGHT BUT WE WANT TO BE AS
COLLABORATIVE IN NATURE AND
UNDERSTANDING THE LEGISLATIVE
INTENT ON ATTACKING THIS ISSUE
BUT MAKING SURE THAT THEY MOMENT
TATIAN IS DONE CREE AND A CRACK
FASHION SO.
I WILL BE CHANGING MY A
RECOMMENDATION AND ALSO MY VOTE
FROM NO TO HI AND WE'LL GET TO
THAT -- WHEN WE GET TO THAT ITEM
WHICH IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
BUT WE'LL GO AND FILE ITEM
NUMBER ORDER WHICH IS FILE --
ONE THIS IS SB FIFTY ONE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG CHAIR
RECOMMENDATION HI.
SB FIFTY WHEN MOTIONS DISASTER
PREPARATIONS CHILL.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I..
GLORIA GLORIA AYE GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
BERMAN I'VE MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN TING.
THE BILL HAS TWELVE VOTES THE
BILL IS OUT.
WE NOW MOVE ON THEN TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER -- TWO THE SB ONE NINETY
THREE BY STE SENATOR NIELSEN AND
NOW IT IS A WRECK -- FOR TO PASS
I RECOMMENDATION.
AS THE ONE NINETY THREE MOTIONS
DEPOSIT APPROPRIATIONS LOW BUT
CHANGE FROM NOTE I CHILL.
CUNNINGHAM.
COMING UP HI GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GORE I'D GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN -- WHEN I MCCARTY?
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN
[inaudible]
TING.
AND THEN ARAMBULA [inaudible]
RAMBLER.
AROUND EVER CHANGE NOT VOTING TO
AYE. THIRTEEN VOTES THE BILL IS
OUT.
FILE I REMEMBER -- FIVE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE SB THREE SEVENTY
SEVEN AND DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE.
SB THREE SEVENTY SEVEN MOTIONS
YOU PASTOR PREPARATIONS CHILL.
CUNNINGHAM -- THIS IS.
CUNNINGHAM I GLORIA.
GORE I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN -- NINTH MCCARTY MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
TING. FOURTEEN VOTES THAT BILL
IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
WHICH IS SB SIX ZERO SIX BY
SENATOR GLACIER DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
AS THE SIXERS EXPOSURES DEPOSIT
AS A MANAGER PREPARATIONS CHILL.
COMING I'M.
COMING I'M AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA -- I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA I MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
AYE TING. SIXTEEN VOTES THE
BILLS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
SB.
SIX ZERO EIGHT A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
SB SIX ZERO EIGHT MOTIONS
DISASTER PREPARATIONS CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
WHEN I GIPSON?
GIPSON AYE GLORIA COR I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN -- WHEN I
MCCARTY?
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
AYE TING [inaudible]
TING I EIGHTEEN ZERO THAT BILL
IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE SB SIX OR
NINE BY CENTER GLAZER DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
SB SIX OH NINE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CHILL.
CUNNINGHAM.
COMING AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
COR I GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA BUT IN AYE
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE AROUND YOU
KNOW TING [inaudible]
THE NUMBER [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
TING AYE. SIXTEEN VOTES THE BILL
WITHOUT FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TEN SB SIX TEN DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
SB SIX TEN MOTIONS YOU PASTOR
PREPARATIONS.
TO CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GORE I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
IRWIN -- WHEN I MCCARTY THE CARD
AND MEDINA WITHIN AYE MULLIN?
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
AYE TING.
TING AYE. EIGHTEEN VOTES THAT
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN
SB SIX TWENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
GALGIANI WHO IS ACCEPTED ALL OF
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND HAS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
SB SIX TWENTY SEVEN MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS
CHILL.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOW.
GLORIA.
GOING AYE HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
IRWIN -- AND I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING [inaudible]
TING AYE. SIXTEEN TO TO THE BILL
IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
WHICH IS SB SIX SEVENTY NINE BY
SENATOR BASE WITH A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
SB SIX THIRTY NINE THIS MOTION
AS YOU PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I CHILL.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE. EIGHTEEN ZERO THE BILL
IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
SB SIX NINETY SEVEN BY SENATOR
COPY OR DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
SB SIX NINETY SEVEN MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHILL.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GLORIA AYE
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
AYE IRWIN.
ARENA MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
AYE TING TING AYE.
HM THIS ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
FINALLY FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN SB -- SEVEN EIGHTY SIX
COMMITTEE BILL PRESENTED BY
SENATOR GLAZIER.
SB SEVEN EIGHTY SIX MOTIONS TO
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS CHILL.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA COR I GRAYSON
REASON I HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN --
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA WITHIN AYE
MULLIN.
WELL I OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE
TING.
TING AYE. EIGHTEEN ZERO THE BILL
IS OUT.
AND THE MEMBERS YOU CAN JUST GO
TO KIND OF COME UP TO THE
COMMITTEES ARE TO JUST ADD ON